the families in the lawsuit against Alex
Jones are demanding
2.75 trillion dollars which is just
about the GDP of France from one guy
Alex Jones because what it's just you
know we're in wacky Wally World levels
of nonsense the children are in charge
nothing makes sense this is ridiculous
maybe Alex Jones will appeal and this
will actually get resolved but I kind of
just feel like the whole system is
imploding like the children are the
inmates are running the asylum the next
story that we'll be talking about is uh
uh Steve Bannon getting four months in
prison for contempt of congress which
once again I mean it's a question of the
Constitution and executive privilege and
there's an argument to be made in over
an administrative issue to sentence the
man to prison I find silly but he's not
going to prison pending appeal so we'll
see how all of that plays out we'll talk
about that plus there's this viral story
the guy in Waukesha who rammed all those
innocent people
oh boy when you see how the media is
writing about this guy a weeping man
with two sides to every story there's a
viral meme going around where when it
was Kyle Rittenhouse they mocked and
belittled him but when it's this guy
they're like well two sides to every
story he weeps we'll talk about all that
before we get started my friends head
over to
strongerbonesandlife.com to pick up your
ageless multi-collagen you need collagen
for your joints your hair your skin your
nails to keep your bones nice and strong
I've I've really messed up my wrist
because I keep just slamming on it but
you know what it's fine because I'm I'm
consuming this had some of my coffee the
other day actually I really do enjoy it
it's good you need it if you want to
stay healthy so strongerbones in
life.com and you will get a 60-day
money-back guarantee the healthy aging
support of collagen in its ideal forms
five key types of college you need from
four different sources and for every
order today BioTrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org today BioTrust has
provided over 5 million meals to Hungry
kids please help them hit their goal of
6 million meals this year it's non-GMO
and free of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners and free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and RBST
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth no clumping none at all you'll get
free shipping with every order and free
VIP live health and fitness coaching
from BioTrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order that alone I got to be honest that
just sounds insane you buy it one time
and then they'll talk with you on the
phone about your health whenever that's
awesome you'll also get their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order so again stronger bones
in life.com thanks for sponsoring the
show BioTrust and don't forget to head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly by clicking
that join us button we got field
reporters I believe we're actually uh
we're sending a field reporter on the
ground to Matt Walsh's big rally in
Tennessee so I'm super excited for that
I'm super proud we're able to do that
shout out to ilad aliyahu who's been
doing field reporting for us I believe
he will be uh covering this I'm not
entirely sure maybe it'll be someone
else but uh it's because you guys our
members were able to do this you'll also
get access to the uncensored members
only show cast Castle Tales from the
inverted world we got more shows coming
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
all this and more is Austin Peterson
thanks for having me back guys who are
you I'm the host of The Wake Up America
show a lifelong Missourian and uh yeah
just a freedom fighter all around
libertarian hardcore you know Fighter
for truth justice in the American way
hey right on just like Superman thanks
for hanging out it should be fun we also
got Lou gradkowski oh oh great it's the
guy who says you can't sell heroin to a
five-year-old
[Laughter]
today I'm wearing a t-shirt with an
updated uh New York State flag which I
think perfectly represents it more
accurately with people running away from
it saying F this place if you like this
shirt you could get it on the best
politicalshorts.com because you do I'm
here thank you again so much for having
me it's Ian Crossland in the house your
favorite free software Advocate Austin
great to see you again as always man
love you brother and Luke thanks dude
nice t-shirt thank you what's going on
Serge hey guys surge.com I'm still gonna
be here pushing the buttons as always
buttons all right here's a story from
Bloomberg
Sandy Hook families seek
2.75 trillion dollars from Alex Jones
Jerry already awarded families 965
million in Damages judge to decide
damages under State deceptive Freight
law oh this is fascinating so basically
they're seeking what just just about 3
000 times what they were awarded from
the jury 2.75 trillion let's put that
into context here is a list of countries
by GDP you can see here U.S dollars in
the trillions France 2.77 Canada 2.2 so
Alex Jones's lawsuit Falls somewhere in
between Canada and France in terms of
gross domestic product that's how stupid
we have become as a people I'm ashamed
because look I'm worried the aliens are
watching us and boy is this embarrassing
if they are you know there's there was a
story we talked about the other day that
claimed Putin had already tried to fire
a nuke but that sabotage or technology
issues cause it not to Fire and I'm like
well the only the only uh you know the
only solution to that the only the only
answer as to why that's happening is
aliens you know as soon as you press the
button the aliens deactivate it well
that's the conspiracy theory right that
aliens stopped us from firing nukes I'm
just saying
the whole world everything that humanity
is we are becoming a clown show that's
how stupid this is so I think we can
take this back you know we can end this
easily going back to late 1700s Congress
shall make no law abridging freedom of
speech now back in those days that only
applied to Congress right but after the
Civil War we passed this thing called
the 14th Amendment says the states now
shall make no law abridging the freedom
of speech so all of the privileges and
immunities of free speech that were
guaranteed in the Constitution applied
to people like Alex Jones there's modern
jurisprudence as well that backs us up
the Supreme Court case that you're going
to want to look to to reference this is
Brandenburg versus Ohio this was back in
the 1960s which says that if there's a
matter of public interest or an event of
public interest if you have an opinion
about that event that is free speech so
this Connecticut judge has essentially
invalidated uh you know jurisprudence
which has been you know repeatedly
upheld since the 1960s it's Brandon bird
case has been tried and tested and has
been settled settled case law so Alex
Jones I think goes to the Supreme Court
and wins I don't think it gets tossed
out on appeal I think it goes to the
Supreme Court and I think that they look
at the Brandenburg case and then they
throw this out entirely let me read this
from the story it says the family said
they're entitled to that amount 2.75
trillion because Jones broke a state law
barring the sale of products using false
statements they reached the sum by
multiplying the state laws five thousand
dollar per violation fine by the 550
million social media exposures Jones's
audience received on his Facebook
YouTube and Twitter accounts in the
three years following the San Diego
incident literally makes no sense the
judge made a huge mistake but but in
this in this regard Alex Jones did not
do come maybe I'm wrong okay but I'm
pretty sure he didn't do commercials
where he held up his progs and was like
I just want to talk about you know a
tragic event buy my product and also
that event was not real like I'm pretty
sure his commercials were entirely
separate statements it would be like if
you know we we have BioTrust sponsors
the show as if they would be liable
because I make a claim about Joe Biden
on the show and that's selling the
product that's nonsense the law is
supposed to be if I said something like
you know this water keeps Tigers away
hundred dollars Ian you want to buy it
well I don't see any tigers do you
that's clearly right that's what they're
trying to go for opinions are always
protected free speech and that's Alex
Jones opinion that that happened and so
as long as it was a clearly stated
opinion about a public event he's
protected so he's never gonna have to
pay this money I mean obviously you know
you guys were talking about it getting
thrown out on appeal but I think that
this goes through the legislative
process goes to the Supreme Court they
say Brandenburg and then it gets tossed
out but you know the left is celebrating
this now as if they're going to go after
all these other people like you and me
and Kanye and others and stuff I don't
think that happens not with the Supreme
Court the way that it sits right now
when he made a statement and named one
of the parents and said that they were
lying that is crosses the line is no
longer opinion is that true no no so uh
here's the crazy thing if I said
something like Ian Crossland is a
conservative commentator who actively
assists fascists and I've seen him do it
that's an opinion
if I said I've watched Ian Crossland
walk up to a group of fascists and
provide Aiden support to them that's an
opinion
because what people need to understand
is that
I've talked with lawyers so many times
about defamation stuff like this people
seem to think that claiming someone did
something is a statement of fact when
it's not but what about if I you said
Ian crosson said he was 43 years old and
he is lying so if you so the statement
of fact is that you said you were 43
years old did you yes okay whether
you're lying or not is my opinion
whether you said you were 43 is fact so
if I said for instance Ian a
conservative commentator Ian Crossland
said that if Young Folks if we get rid
of no fault divorce Young Folks would be
more careful about who they marry did
you really say that because I made a
statement of fact and a quote like
Jezebel so is it for those that are
familiar this is literally what Jezebel
did to Ian this is a false statement to
fact outright and it is actionable the
next question is Damages were you
damaged by it how much does it cost well
we had one user tell us the other day
they were going to give us a thousand
bucks a month for 84 years but then they
found out Ian was conservative so
they're not gonna so what we'll have to
look into for 2.75 trillion that's right
2.75 marks of people that have watched
the show ever and thought of me in their
head now multiplied by come on so so the
issue with this is that uh Alex Jones
never had a trial that's that's that's
what happened if he did they would have
been like it's a it's a it's an opinion
albeit you might think it's a really
stupid one but it is the judge granted
um discovery which makes no sense I mean
she should have immediately ruled it as
a free speech issue but you know she's
obviously stepped into this on the on a
political side a lot of people think and
I agree Alex should not have said stuff
like this it's it's clearly ridiculous
but he's allowed to you know uh Ethan
Klein got suspended from from YouTube
the other day for the comments he made
about Ben Shapiro getting guessed we
said it on the show that night he should
not get suspended that was before he did
and then I said it again he got banded
he shouldn't be he should be allowed to
say that someone super chatted already
that like I'm criticizing Kanye West for
saying you know I don't know if we're
supposed to say it on the show because
someone's at the R1 yeah but I'm like
you know kind I said Kanye shouldn't I
didn't say he should be banned from
doing it right but what about the
defamation case now in your opinion what
should somebody not be able to say like
when they can prove damages by what
someone said when they're not a public
figure right well so I I I understand
the public figure thing and it's it's
tough right if if we're looking at
someone who is a politician or a
celebrity and they're active in public
life and we have an argument with them I
understand why we have the time see
times V Sullivan precedent that there's
a higher standard for public figures
for people who aren't public figures who
aren't involved in this stuff I
understand why that standard isn't there
so it is difficult my my view of this is
like what really should have happened is
that they sue Alex Jones and said you've
made false statements about this Alex
Jones pays in the thousands and has to
issue an apology under attraction I
think one big solution for a lot of
these things is a retraction and apology
but the courts don't ever enforce that
but he's injection right now Alex
already did Issue a lot of apologies no
I know but YouTube deleted all those
videos and there's no record of it right
there's not a lot of records that he
could comply with and this is one of the
reasons why of course they just threw
out the court case and he didn't have
his day in court they just decided he
was guilty said he wasn't complying
maybe he was maybe he wasn't we don't
know the full story of exactly what was
happening behind the scenes here but uh
I don't know maybe these families
confused Alex Jones with the Federal
Reserve and think he could just print
money out of thin air and it's just a
ridiculous notion to ask for trillions
of dollars it shows you how frivolous
this is and how it's politically
motivated rather than motivated on the
actual Marathon of this case yeah I
think I I think the strong possibility
goes to the Supreme Court they might
just say they don't want to hear it but
I think they probably would because this
is kind of ridiculous so here's my
understanding I was uh we went down to
Austin I think it was a year ago
and this was when Jones was right right
on time he was held in default are they
declared a default judgment because he
didn't turn over all the documents
Alex I was talking to him and he said we
have given them every single thing we
have there's nothing else we can give
them and he was like frantically and
adamant being like Tim wasn't like I
gave him literally everything I don't
know what else to do and they just kept
saying he didn't yeah so like what do
you do when they just claim you didn't
give them the documents and you did he's
in chapter 11 which means that in Texas
he's still going to be able to operate
he's got like less than three million
dollars in assets they don't have to
liquidate he can still keep his
employees he can still operationally but
that what they've promised is all the
future profits from which there never
will be that right right let me explain
something to to uh anybody who just
doesn't understand how businesses work
profits are a choice that's it it's a
choice
so they may try and say okay we're gonna
we're gonna find out where you are right
now and we're gonna say here's a cap as
to how much you can use for our
operational costs but that probably
won't fly because it makes no sense
because costs vary so for Alex let's say
he makes three million dollars this year
I I was probably way more a while ago
let's make let's let's just pick a
number let's say 10 million okay fine
they say okay you made 10 million
dollars
that is revenue not profit Alex can then
take let's say it costs him 3 million to
run the business he can then spend seven
million dollars on advertisements all
over the country and that is an
operational cost he can just choose to
dump it into things he can buy more
machines he can build a bigger Warehouse
he can build a bigger studio and just
keep spending the money they will never
see a penny yeah this looks right this
was a political judgment it's not a
legal precedent that said it's going to
get overturned you know Alex Jones will
continue to be able to operate in Texas
so I honestly I think that probably
everybody benefits from this in the end
because when it does go to the Supreme
Court and they do uphold the Brandon
Brandenburg precedent people like you
and I are going to be benefiting from
we're going to get the Alex Jones
president and then we're going to be
like did you see that court case between
you know Ethan Klein and Ben Shapiro
well well under the Jones Alex Jones
precedent they're going to have to
they're going to hate that so much like
we've got keep bringing up the man's
name that we banned everywhere on social
media in in Jones V so um this is what
happened in Mississippi with the
abortion ban they it was what 11 weeks
or something then the left sued to stop
it and it resulted in Roe v Wade getting
overturned they could have just said hey
let's not launch any lawsuits until we
get control of the Supreme Court to keep
this level but they decided we're gonna
go we're gonna go at this and try and
fight it makes the Supreme Court Supreme
Court says no Roe v Wade gone yeah see
this is why I don't take the black pill
man I am so on the white pill train
because over the long course of History
Liberty has advanced if you look at
things on a long enough timeline sure
have we lost some short-term victories
sure but the Libertarians have slowly
made gotten the big wins Roe v Wade was
a big one that wasn't that happened last
the first time I was on the show last
time and the anarchists and the people
who want to be left alone we would see
things a little bit differently but but
you do make a very good point because
especially when it comes to states
rights especially when it comes to gun
rights we have seen it grow in in a way
that the federal government has been
having a hard time trying to of course
stop you look at people where you look
at States where people could conceal
carry they're they're becoming more and
more abundant by the day that's a huge
major victory and I I think when we look
at you know the decentralization
decentralization of power there's a lot
of optimism there's a lot of Hope but
also at the same time I think we're
seeing the system panic and kind of get
angry and lash out and I think this is
one of the ways that they're lashing out
in these kind of particular court cases
but at the end of the day we're talking
about Alex Jones someone that of course
is banned on social media and if
anything this is only going to make him
more notable this is only going to make
more people know about it because more
people are talking about them now so he
was a famous guy but they've turned him
into an iconic historical figure
literally that's the craziest thing
about it a martyr yeah but I mean just I
mean more than that
Alex Jones for a while was just a
personality he was a guy who talked and
in P had fans if they left him alone he
would have ended up in the in the
history historical record as a guy who
said stuff online now they've turned him
into an extremely consequential
political and legal figure with
everything they've gone after now in
throughout history there's going to be
precedent historical records talking
about the conflict the crisis the
politics all of that stuff just simply
put he used to be influential now he's
consequential that's that's the song
lyric the left the left didn't read
their Niche they stared too long into
the abyss they fought they fought
dragons and then they became the enemy
they became exactly what they were
fighting against you know who else is
you know red pill and a lot of people
and another big victory for free speech
and freedom is Corey deangelis's Crusade
for school choice in Arizona yes he's
winning Glenn Younkin in Virginia the
governor's race I mean what a blessing
that has been but I honestly think that
that the school choice issue and the
freedom of choice in education is the
freedom issue of our time the pandemic
red pills a lot of people but there's
nothing like telling parents that they
shouldn't have anything to do with their
kids education to get people to show up
to their town that on top of a new
record number of homeschoolers also
throughout the last few years has been
growing very significantly especially
after covid when a lot of people were
able able to actually see what's what's
happening in their curriculum what's
happening in their schools and be
shocked by the utter craziness that's
being taught to students and it's not
really teaching students or teaching
kids anything it's really indoctrinating
them into the current system a lot of
people are sick of it a lot of people
are saying you know what I'm just going
to teach my own kids the important
things that I want to teach them and
what I love too is seeing all of the
former liberals coming along to our side
right and like how the trans issue has
turned so many of the LGBT or the LGBT
well the LGBT community we get you know
Blair white and so many other
transgender people Sarah Higdon and
others who are coming along to our side
have been red pilled because of the
extremism of the progressive values the
progressives are out there attacking
Alexandria Casa Cortez in a town halls
the push to this
hang on yeah sticks our tongue out it's
like did she vote for funding for
Ukraine for weapons it was unanimous it
was unanimous so wait a minute unanimous
Thomas Massey didn't vote no no no the
Democrats oh okay like there was like no
defectors you look at the Republicans
and it's split but so with uh with with
a lot of this ideology stuff there's
there's one really great example that's
popping in the news and it's this Dylan
Mulvaney I think the individual's name
is uh it's some of the funniest kind I
mean Dylan Dylan says that they're a
performer putting on a performance and I
respect that and think the performance
is very very funny the only thing is
it's at the expense of women right Dylan
Mulvaney Frozen familiar posted his
video got invited to the White House and
got a cookie and the whole performance
and again I'll stress this Mulvaney says
outright that this is a performance I
bring that up and people are like no
it's serious no it's serious and I'm
like I mean maybe Dylan's literally
trans but the character they're playing
is exaggerated over the top performance
and it's you know when they say Woman
face I'm like no that that's literally
what this is right it's it's you the
point I'm trying to make is
you mentioned that even trans people are
getting concerned about what's going on
Blair white being a good example because
Dylan Mulvaney's character is a
caricature of women and trans people not
indicative of who trans people really
are so you have this person who's TripIt
wearing high heels while going hiking
and and just this very cartoonish
character yeah and it's got It's got a
lot of trans people and women angry that
they're being mocked by this performance
well conservatism is not confined to one
ideology right there there are
conservative Democrats right they're
conservative gay people right so you
know conservatism can Encompass a wider
branch of philosophies than most people
might might think it's not consider it's
not confined to republicanism but hey uh
you know Biden really likes Dylan
Mulvaney and according to Dylan who came
out today he says that Biden said that
he watches his Tick Tock Channel and
that they're going to going to come out
with an official conversation and
interview this coming Sunday so that's
going to be very interesting to watch
but but to the point that you guys are
making here I think it's important to
note here that you know a lot of times
when people are a part of different
communities especially in the
conservative kind of wing they usually
don't make it their personality
sometimes they do and it's a little bit
annoying but when you just come to the
table and say hey my sex my gender my
choice of how I decide to procreate is
everything all about me it's kind of
annoying and it kind of takes away from
the human being and that's what you see
from a lot when it comes to a lot of
these social media personalities that
just use it as a way to have a fake
personality I think it's possible to get
to the point well I see one of two
features one where offensive comedy
comes back with it with a Vengeance and
you start seeing like remember when
Sarah said priors and stuff yeah yeah I
mean when George Carlin George Collins
George Carlin called Richard Pryor and
Eddie Murphy the n-word on stage to
thunder supplies like I mean it's it's
shocking it's true but it's true yeah he
did outright and the point he was making
is that it was a joke because you know
they're not like it was meant to be
absurd you know that George Carlin is a
hippie who doesn't really believe in the
stuff and he was meant it was meant to
be shocking and offensive but you can't
do that kind of stuff these days maybe
it'll go swing in the complete other
direction or maybe
it will come to the point where Woman
face becomes extremely offensive and
people like Dylan Mulvaney get banned
for a for
um misogyny but how do you do that I
mean like do you how do you rally women
around that to like to reclaim Womanhood
that doesn't that it isn't some entirely
conservative female movement I mean our
liberal females really going to get on
board with a reclaiming you know Woman
face like so I mean you've gotta well my
point is maybe I'm not saying right now
I mean I don't know where we're at I
just wonder what the psychology is there
have to be some kind of polarizing event
I I what I what I see is either the
woman face phenomenon results in people
saying mockery of any identity is is
fair play or it turns into you know what
we've realized for some time that's
probably not okay to mock women in this
way
but shouldn't it be okay though
shouldn't it be shouldn't it shouldn't
everybody be up for grabs like when you
were kids there was always that one
serious kid who told the teacher every
time somebody said something mean about
him and then the rest of us were all
having a laugh or having a joke right I
mean I don't I don't think it should be
illegal or banned or anything like that
but people are allowed to have tastes
you know what I mean like like Sarah
Silverman did blackface personally I'm
not a fan of it George Carlin a huge fan
of but his joke where he calls Eddie
Murphy and Richard probably the n-word
that's I'm not I'm not all about that
you know I understand his point about
being offensive I think he should be
allowed to do it I think he can make his
joke and turns out tons of people really
loved what he said good for him I you
know that's not my thing for blackface
you know what I mean is it like is there
you know let's say you're doing a
documentary or a film about Al Jolson
right so I mean like there is a time and
place to do blackface right so I mean
the only thing that we're calling out
Sarah Silverman for is the hypocrisy of
the last right right because she did
blackface but you mean doing blackface
in so far as you're mocking what it what
it represented yes like the the joke of
modern blackface with someone like Sarah
Silverman was that you're you're sort of
making fun of the old ways when when
these people were racist and it was
wrong and you're supposed to be shocked
by it and it's funny because it's deeply
offensive you know what I mean like
wasn't that what Al Jolson was doing
though originally like he was doing a
parody of the Blackfish not only that
but like RDJ like Robert Downey Jr in
that movie Tropic Thunder all right
right right specifically this it's
exactly what we're talking about to poke
fun at the people who do it yes right
they were I think the traffic Thunder is
hilarious it is and the gag was actors
who go too far into method acting and it
went so far he actually did blackface he
well it's more than that like his
character got like skin pigmentation
like it's a while I I just say
personally myself let people say and do
and express themselves as they want as
long as they don't physically hurt other
people people should be able to control
their own emotions we shouldn't be
policing conversation speech and art let
it express itself and if someone wants
to be distasteful that is their uh
perspective and opinion but it's also
your opinion to get triggered and angry
and emotional about it so at the end of
the day people's words and actions only
have power if you give them that power
and I think if a lot of more of us were
more mature about this we we could have
a situation where we didn't have
censorship we didn't have of course the
destruction of free speech and the
progression of society but sadly we we
do because people saying I don't like
this this is offending me stop him right
now and I think that's just weak and I
think that's that's that's well as with
a low vibrational energy that's not good
for human consciousness well as of a lot
of things right like the woke people
will take like a grain of Truth and then
spin it around it a yarn of Lies so
emotional abuse is a real thing right a
use of institutional power to
emotionally abuse an affected group
that's a real thing the problem is is
that when you take it when you take that
and then you liberalize it and you
expand it into you know an entire web
then you go too far and then there's
going to be collateral damage so the
question is how do you define what is
emotional abuse that's the problem right
that's the the realm of therapists to be
able to answer a question like that
maybe you guys know more than I do but
at some point you know I hate bullies
right I can't stand bullies you know
when you see somebody being bullied
because of their race or their sexuality
or something like that you want to stand
up against that right at least I do
right that for me I'm not a conservative
I'm a Libertarian so how do you do that
right without saying oh you're you're
just a woke social justice where you're
taking the side of the left or something
like that how do you stand up for the
rights of affected minorities from
actual emotional abuse without crossing
over into something larger effective I
just want to say confront the bully
directly to their friends Dave Chappelle
I think said it best you don't like it
don't watch it if you don't like what I
say you don't have to listen to it you
choose to watch and listen certain
things and if you don't like someone you
don't like their taste that you you got
offended by them don't watch them it's
your choice at the end of the day
remember that Viral tweet that I think
it was Tyler the Creator and he said how
is cyber bullying a real thing like Just
Close Your Eyes just like turn the
screen off kind of work but here's the
thing we're guys we're all guys we don't
have any women at this table those young
girls bully the the absolute hell out of
each other and these when they're on
their social media with the things that
they're saying the bullying in high
school it's not like when we were
growing up guys it's different but in
the pictures they've got nudes of each
other they they reach you at home
they're you know it's an insane level of
harassment yeah so this is actually it's
a good point because for these kids it
used to be that if you went to school
and you had problems when you went home
you were safe from what that stressor
was but the next day you had to go face
it today with social media and online
personas it's it's Infinity it's never
going anywhere and so we're seeing
suicide we're seeing depression mostly
among young girls so yeah I mean I think
I think really it's going to come down
to the parents to be like no cell phone
for you is the depression because of
bullying or is it because of the
algorithms that perfectly highlight and
curate and and upvote particular context
that causes drama that causes anger that
gets people's attention and they know if
they say something negative they'll get
people responding to it if they post
something degenerate they're they'll get
more eyeball and the algorithm will
reward them for this and I think I think
there's an argument to be made here
because you know I grew up in New York
City I grew up in Brooklyn there there
was bullying on insane levels there was
there was a kid who who you know one day
wasn't coming in for a few months he was
burnt all throughout his body he lost
his father in a fire there was a bully
calling him sausage face punching him
beating him up psychological abuse where
you couldn't escape it there was gangs
there was people bullying each other to
the extent where you couldn't even go
outside in many instances because you
would get you know kicked in stomped on
I got stomped on a couple times I got I
got bullied like crazy because I didn't
even okay so so I'm saying there always
was bullying yes but but but who are you
gonna you know point the finger at to
well so the algorithm or the individual
it's both it's both but I just want to
point out because there's a cultural
issue at play with all of this you
mentioning this kid who got burned I
gotta tell you man where I grew up if
anybody bullied the burn kid that bully
would get stomped out in the playground
yeah like dude everybody was kind of
like bro you crossed the line and that's
a cultural phenomenon of kids who had
some kind of moral code or just like
Scruples sounds like where you came from
it was different yeah and there no one
like this bully knew he could do it
nobody would stop him yeah it was a
bigger kid who got left back a bunch of
times and everyone was afraid of him so
this and he would beat the crap out of
anybody and anyone he wanted yeah this
is kind of messed up so when I was uh
when I was 14 years old my mother passed
away from cancer and you know it was
traumatizing event I watched the whole
thing happen in real time in front of my
face you know just a horrible horrible
event took an entire year of suffering
and my best friend you know knew that I
was depressed like it was about six
months or so after she passed away and
you know nothing would make me laugh
nothing could crack like I was just in a
funk and then one day we were talking
about something and he just turns me and
he goes yeah well at least my mom isn't
dead
and I just went
oh and I just started laughing so hard
it broke me out of my phone and I just
started laughing again I don't know what
it was but I do think and I'm not trying
to be like you know soft here but I do
think we are coming at this from a very
masculine world view like like because
like we are told to top be tough be hard
you know and a lot of this a lot of the
you know a lot of this leftist stuff
comes from feminism and feminists of
women who wanted to be soft and wanting
to take care of people's feelings and
wanting to protect people which I
totally understand right you want to
come into the heat get ready to get
burned I agree I agree but you gotta
understand that like a a big portion of
what we are opposing here in wokism is
post-modern feminism right and that
that's that's feelings over facts right
so we've got to be sensitive to that in
order to have a conversation with people
who think that we're we're insensitive
and that we're not thinking about that
we're these hard cold Randy and
unfeeling Libertarians so what you're
saying is that you know men are smart
logical and tough and women are frail
weak and that's what you said
you mentioned before that I'm using
institutional power full of guys
emotionally abuse someone is over the
line and I agree with you and I think
the definition of institutional power
has changed since internet videos become
so prominent now a 13 year old that has
700 000 followers on Tick Tock is the
institutional power and for a young
unfocused child just to let their
wildness out on another human is like
heavily abusive and and dangerous and
can rally crowds of people to do it so
what do you say to him toughen up kid
you know you got 13 million followers
you know you're aiming it at them you're
telling them to go and harass them
essentially you just say Hey kid this is
the world that you live in now you know
these aren't problems that we use they
don't seem to work you can't like tell
someone to stop on this you got a ban
that well what they've been doing is
Banning them off the platform right and
that's like I don't know if that's the
way to go yeah when I was at VidCon this
is maybe seven or eight years ago that's
ancient I'm out in front of um it's an
Anaheim Convention Center I'm out in
front
I think on my skateboard on my skating
and I hear there's a group of little
kids like probably 12 13 and one kid
goes you have 85 subscribers how and
then he's like I just made videos and
the kid was like I have 40. like these
kids are talking to each other about how
many followers they have that freaked me
out I was like that's gonna warp those
kids Minds their whole world is going to
be attached to the number of points they
get their influence numbers like what I
want to say about like you know Ben
Shapiro he's his famous statement you
know facts don't care about your
feelings he's right about that but
that's from our world view the outside
world feelings don't care about our
facts well I've long said that and a lot
of a lot of other people have said that
same thing too and that's the more
important thing to understand Ben
Shapiro is factually correct facts don't
care about feelings but you need to
understand in the political the
political reality is that their feelings
don't care about your facts so how do we
learn this language right how do we this
is like learning a brand new language we
have to be able to learn this language
in order to be able to counteract it I
think no no no look look you're correct
but we know the language I I used to do
non-profit fundraising it's evil I think
I think these industry I think the
industry is evil I think I realize that
life's organizations were just lying and
that what they teach people is
specifically the language of feelings
they give you scripts they break down
how the scripts work so they teach you
exactly how to speak their language and
you know what there are hype there are
high functioning individuals who can
build a podcast or a media platform
knowing that language
that means they're probably manipulating
their followers or you can be the quote
unquote right and have real
conversations often disagree and say
it's cool that we disagree but not try
to use emotional manipulation really
what it comes down to is on a show like
this if we tried to engage in Hearts
office tree we'd get annihilated by by
the audience they would say you guys are
liars and it's obvious because I think
what's really starting to split the Two
Worlds is facts versus feelings and the
people who are all about facts aren't
going to be swayed by emotional
manipulation that's most of the people
who are watching this show and the
inverse and then it's the inverse you
watch a show like uh like h3h3 or or
Hassan and it's going to be all
emotional manipulation with very little
facts hence the Democrats right now will
say we gotta get off fossil fuels and
shut down the Keystone Pipeline hey
Saudi Arabia keep pumping that gas how
can both of those things be true but do
we want this balkanization I guess is
the question I mean if you're an
anarchist then yeah you want to you know
break everybody up into separate
Independence republics of individuals
right but if you want to live in the
United States like do you want Hassan to
come on this show and talk to you
because right now we are we exactly
but that's is that what we want no we
want I want you know Hassan to come in
here and engage with us I want to talk
to these people I want to have these
conversations when I reach out to
leftists and liberals to try and get
them on the show they won't do it listen
Ethan Klein got suspended on YouTube
because he said that um if there is
another
if there's another Holocaust he hopes
that uh Ben goes first which is shocking
and defensive now my position Ben's
position and most people in our space
was basically like he shouldn't be
banned for that he's just kind of a dick
Ethan Klein himself tweeted before that
cancel culture is often a good thing and
when he's been canceled in the past it
helps him reflect and become a better
person when he got his sponsors pulled
because he made gay stereotype jokes he
said well I guess I'm a threat to gay
people so you know whatever and he was
kind of bummed about it when he makes
offensive comments about Ben Shapiro he
claimed white supremacists got him
banned well I'm sorry I got to pause
there a second you mean you made a joke
about guessing Ben and you thought white
supremacists were mad about it they I'm
sorry they agree with you Ethan but it's
it but my point is
it's it's nonsensical there's no logic
there there's no fact to follow he's
saying two things that contradict each
other however in the world of emotion
that doesn't matter so of course it's
true we are in this world where we look
for logical consistency and we often
don't understand how they could be
trapped in that world because they don't
need logical consistency they need
emotional consistency and what's that
hating us well it was no I think uh
Ethan was J was joking and jiving Ben
like it was an emotional an attempt to
emotionally bond with Ben Shapiro are
you kidding dude I know how people like
that you're saying you're saying that
Ethan Klein saying he hopes Ben Shapiro
gets gassed was to bond with that he's
like listen fellow Jew take take
responsibility for your jewishness let's
be together on this one like kind of
thing it was an emotional way to say
that and it came out as a dirty joke
emotional in the sense that it would
make the average person want to fight
you I guess yeah kind of like with a
friend and you're like no make an
insulting joke to your friend oh yeah
and then you get like a bonding kind of
no way dude so you are that is a one
times one like hold on look when you are
a personality that consistently attacks
insults derides and makes it makes money
off of harming like like attacking other
people and then one day you go on your
show and outright say you hope if it
comes down to it they die I'm sorry bro
and you're not attacking other people
you mean insulting other people I don't
like no sort of attack used in
conversational terms it's not you're not
attacking each other like these are
these are people who celebrated cancel
culture celebrated the the harm to
people's livelihoods and then complain
when it happens to them they advocate
for a world of pain and then demand it
does not befall them when look if if I
said this the other day if I came out
and said similar comments about AOC
ain't nobody's gonna call that a joke
we're critical of AOC we're not friends
with her he is not friends with Ben
Shapiro no what he said about him was
not bonding it was a dog it was an
attempt to bond oh come on through a
motion it was an attempt emotional
attempt to bond it was an attempt to
write an insult for the sake of making
money why would he bond with somebody
that he argues with and doesn't like
politically and and is is complete
different
uh natural human tendency can I take an
informal poll amongst you guys on the
subject of national divorce yay or nay
nay no no yay okay so I'm a nay uh as
well so we got one yay what about you
search
um I think the US is strong because it's
many different nations maybe if it was a
divorce where it was kind of like larger
regions the United States maybe okay so
it's like a larger balkanization okay
but I don't I don't necessarily know I
wouldn't be able to say that so then yay
so then that means that we've got to
figure out a way to live with these
people right Bill Maher's been talking
about this on his show a couple of times
no we don't have to figure out a way to
build these people no we don't that's
why we have States and that's why people
have championed federalism well because
Canada states have Democrats in them
that's that's that's fine and the
internet California can do its
California's thing so long as we outline
where they're infringe upon our rights
for instance California allowing tons of
illegal immigrants to come in then using
that in the census to gain a
congressional seat or an electoral vote
is a violation of our rights that needs
to be adjudicated but if California
wants to have illegal immigrants that
don't count toward their senses I could
care less look how can we live in a
country with with people who think that
we are semi-fascists right how can we
live how can we call those people our
country listen
Luke and say National divorce right
listen we tolerate that there are
countries in this world that want us all
dead we need to find a way to not fight
with each other war is bad yes yes so
the same goes for even within this
country I think California is a very
awful place there's poop in the streets
they they ignore federal laws the only
thing I'm concerned about is there are
benefits to being part of the Union that
make us strong and protect us from say
Chinese communism Chinese Communist
party but I don't like the fact that
when they become a sanctuary State and
defy federal law it gives them Federal
power that should be adjudicated I think
if it came down to it a peaceful divorce
is better than a civil war but I would
prefer this country remain together in
fact I prefer the United States actually
expand buying Greenland let's agree
let's get it we need to add more States
uh
I don't want Canada
I know the oil is
it that doesn't matter I like Montreal
you don't have to deal with all of
Canada
if you guys just listen to me and do
what I want Let's see we can avoid a
whole bunch of properties I I think it's
important to prioritize you know when I
talk about National divorce when I'm
specifically talking about is
prioritizing states rights limiting the
federal government allowing people to
individually decide their own kind of
Destiny but at the same time you could
also have defense packs you could also
say hey we're going to protect each
other hey we're going to have a strong
National Defense if one of us gets
attacked we're going to have an alliance
but the federal government that dictates
how we should be living our life that's
just too much there we don't need all
these departments we don't need all
these Regulators we don't need all these
rules we don't need all these taxes we
could go states by state
independentalism Alexander Hamilton
federalism but at the same time that
would mean a peaceful divorce because
we're not reliant on the federal
government keeping us together no no no
a very weak federal government for the
purpose of of shared National Defense
roads and things like that for the most
part we're talking about federalism you
keep the roads I don't want the roads
let the roads be private that's not how
the whole Road conversation
but Luke the first thing that's going to
happen is Missouri's going to war with
Kansas I don't think so I I think
they'll uh why why would you why well
you guys must not be from Missouri first
of all Jayhawks border War we've had a
problem with them since the late 1800s
but uh that was what Alexander Hamilton
argued in the Federalist was that if we
do not have a central federal government
that puts us all in a 50 you know
whatever the arrangement was 13 colonies
13 states at the time that they they
would be more willing to go to war with
one another and that the tensions
between the states will be alleviated
because they could seek redress
throughout the federal government and I
think that that argument has been proven
true I I and I think that's actually
fantastic and it's it's partly how I
describe uh International efforts or I
don't want to say globalism because that
that is a connotation towards because of
One World Government if we were all
under like Star Trek kind of a situation
but I'm saying this imagine the United
States had Sovereign rights over its
borders and trade but instead of War we
adjudicated things through a court it's
preferable Baltimore I don't want to see
our troops overseas blowing up anybody
or getting blown up I don't want to see
nukes fired as much as it might suck
it's better so in that sense there is a
path towards
can I one more one thing real quick Luke
I want to blow your mind here with a
little like situation here in the
globalist thing right would you rather
live on an earth that was a one world
government that was governed under the
United States Constitution or would you
rather live in a world where it had
hundreds of of governments but they were
all like North Korea one one world
government with a constitution right so
I mean you're a globalist no I I I've
never I've I've often talked about this
Global inevitable I've often said how
are we going to do so one world
government is inevitable in your mind
yeah it is Luke get him no it's true I
was just gonna say that's the argument I
was going to make because because what
you were just saying essentially if
you're saying oh we're all going to be
together so we don't fight each other
why don't we just create a world
government just like you know the
Rockefellers has called for incentives
but this
is the court of my argument right
there's centralization of power there's
a monopoly power and then there's
decentralization I think we should
always be striving and pushing and
advocating for the decentralization of
power not for the centralization because
when you centralize it enough you have a
world government and that's essentially
the wet dream of many Eugenics
you're conflating a bunch of issues that
don't need to be conflated right your
point about a one world governor of the
American Constitution is a good one if
it was actually the American
Constitution that's a really really good
thing the issue here is you are correct
about decentralization of power Luke but
simply because we would have a very weak
treaty between countries for
adjudication of Border disputes and
resource disputes does not mean
eugenicists will start massacring
children of course not just like you
were talking about annexing Canada right
so if we added a 51st state what you're
talking about is moving towards
essentially that one world government
what if Russia was just a state what if
Mexico was just a state right and then
everyone was governor see that's why
like you have to be careful when you say
oh well decentralization is good because
ultimately you could say well you know
North Korea is very decentralized but
it's not governed very well right so the
question really is is are individual
rights protected that's what I think is
really important and so the question is
is when we talk about big government is
it the size of government that matters
or is it if that government protects
individual rights and these are
questions to ask myself I don't know the
answer to that because but the American
government is bigger than North Korea
but I would rather live in the American
government that is bigger but everyone
works for the government in North Korea
but this is the thing and there's a
correlation between big governments and
Liberty going down so when you look at
that correlation historically this is
why you always
government is bigger than our government
the North Korean government is absolute
in their country from border to border
every everyone works for the government
is is controlled by the government and
enslaved by the government but there are
plenty of objective measures that the
United States government is much larger
than that you're making your secretary
yes but hold on you're making an
argument employee okay okay I get it
you're making an argument about hard
number to number if I'm talking about
crime in Omaha Nebraska and New York
what matters the hard numbers of murders
or the per capita murders per capita per
capita if we're talking about the size
of government North Korea is as big as
government can be just because they're a
small country physically does not mean
they're a smaller government than ours
100 percent government everybody's in
the government so it's I agree
everyone's applying for the government
there's what percentage of the
population is involved with working for
the government yeah with the United
States I mean look at New York New York
has between 30 and 40 000 cops out of uh
2.5 million just in Manhattan alone that
is very little government enforcement
relative to the size of the population I
disagree you're wrong and I'll tell you
why because if the government of the
United States wanted to accomplish what
North Korea is doing it could in many
ways it does the size of the government
can be met you what you said is a
subjective measurement we I could take
my own measurements and say yeah
the the laws of North Korea that exists
Define what you mean by government size
okay I'm talking about the budget the
national budget I'm talking about the
number of Bureau bureaucracies that
exist the number of bureaucrats that
work in those bureaucracies a number of
offices appointed offices right the size
and scope of the U.S federal government
by any objective measure other than what
that government can do to its citizens
and the power that it has over its
citizens by that measurement I would
give that to you North Korea is a larger
government in that it can reach into its
citizens lives and accomplish more in
controlling its citizens lives in the
U.S federal government which I think is
what matters right it that is what
matters so the problem but there can be
an argument made that the United States
I would disagree with your assessment is
that population size doesn't dictate
size of government in any meaningful way
just because there's 330 million people
here by necessity you have people who
work in government a certain percentage
but that percentage is minuscule
Compared to North Korea right but it's
my point that it doesn't matter
necessarily what the size of government
is stands because you would still rather
live in a government that is governed
under the United States in a world that
is going under the U.S Constitution then
it then it is one that is decentralized
republics but they're all governed by
like North Korea but I would even
encounter saying no one even respects
the Constitution anymore do you think
New York State respects the Second
Amendment they don't they absolutely
don't and and this idea to change their
laws to adjust to what the Supreme Court
has done suggests that you're incorrect
I I yeah yeah but at the same time look
look what the reality is in New York
state look what the reality that a lot
of people are living under when their
basic rights are being violated by the
NSA by the federal government spying on
everything you would get rid of the U.S
Constitution uh absolutely not uh but
but I would say the government is
imperfect but one of the the most
closest you know better ideas is of
course the Constitution but now we have
to face the reality
foreignly a lot of federal bureaucrats
because there's so much government they
don't respect to the Constitution the
idea of the Constitution is something
that they don't even know and understand
because of how big our bureaucracy is
and I would even argue that just two
years ago we lived under a North Korean
type government that went around locked
down businesses and shut people's
livelihoods down and made them not even
be able to uh you know walk around
freely in many instances depending on
your state didn't happen to us in
Missouri exactly why because
decentralization because states are able
to decide what's right for themselves
but if he lived in Australia right the
court cases that came out used the U.S
Constitution as precedent so it was the
Federal Government ultimately and the
14th amendment that many of these court
cases relied on so without if we had
gone into you know National divorce Luke
how could we how could you have used the
Constitution as president you say they
ignored it but I mean the court cases
suggest otherwise and and and when Alex
Jones Goes to the Supreme Court right it
will be the fed the federal laws that he
will use to protect him and his Free
Speech but a lot of times that is
interpreted up to the judges to make
decisions that are not always beholden
to the Constitution the Constitution is
not a perfect idea but it's one of the
best perfect ideas that we have come
close to and I agree with you we should
try to protect the Constitution but at
the same time we live in a reality where
it's just been thrown to the side and we
can't deny that right but so let's say
idealistically
if if the whole world is governed
governed according to the US
Constitution that would that be a good
thing yes if people respect to the
Constitution yes you think so sort of it
won't be a perfect but but it's it's
there it's better than what we have okay
what do you think yeah I think it's a
start for sure what do you think Serge
uh I think it's like like Ian said I
think it's a start I think it's a start
the I I think for one we're biased we
are all people who benefited from the US
Constitution live in a country where we
see its values there are probably people
in say China who firmly believe in the
hierarchy of the Chinese Communist party
and they're just like it's horrifying If
people could lie and say whatever they
wanted it would harm the greater I'm
sure they would disagree with us we're
very individualists as a nation and I
think it's actually fascinating if you
look back as to why that is a bunch of
people lived in Europe the people who
wanted to stay and be a part of the
collective and live under that rule
stayed a bunch of other people for a
variety of reasons said I would rather
live in a Barren you know Barren
Shoreline and figure it out so what
happens is you have a bunch of human
beings in Europe and there's the crown
there's the church there's war and
conflict and many people say I'm gonna
stay a bunch of people forever for
religious reasons or political reasons
get in a boat 20 or so die on the boat
they land on shores that are empty and
say I'm gonna I'm gonna make my own
thing here that small group of people
had a bunch of kids those kids resulted
in us surprise surprise hundreds of
millions of people now were staunchly
individualist that means we're going to
have those values and we want the rest
of the world to retain those values for
one reason because of how we live and
how we think it is beneficial for other
people to live absolutely you know
interventionism right this is why you
know foreign policy Wise It's good to
let other countries do it I believe in
Liberty but not enough to force it on
anyone else just one more argument I
wanted to make here and this is why I
always believe that that
decentralization is the key individual
rights are the key here is is like the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court is
supposed to uphold the Constitution
right it's supposed to be the checks and
balances but it depends if there's
Democrats in power or if there's
Republicans in power what kind of laws
you're going to get and that's not
because of the Constitution that's
because of political partisanship with
people being activist judges deciding
for themselves you know what I like this
idea we're in power we're going to do
this and we're going to force these
ideas onto everyone and that to me is a
bad idea and I think if we've respected
people's individual rights and then just
go by this system things would be a lot
okay here's the thing so you're in a
paradox right We're All in This Paradox
right and this is we're going back to
the Federalists versus the
Anti-Federalists here and the writing of
the Bill of Rights in the Constitution
the Anti-Federalists didn't want the
Constitution to be ratified so when they
knew that it was going to happen they
said okay well if you're going to do
this we are going to write down these
rights and they came up with a Bill of
Rights right the problem is is that the
Anti-Federalists didn't believe that
things like laws and rights really
needed to be written down but the
Federalists Alexander Hamilton George
Washington and others they all said to
themselves well in order to have a
proper law it has to be written down so
the the Anti-Federalists didn't believe
that but they knew that their enemies
did they knew that their enemies
believed that so they said you know what
we know that if we do not write down
these 10 rules then they are going to
take away our rights I think it becomes
that Paradox was it okay so it was this
Paradox where it's like well we don't
believe in written law but we know that
they do and if we don't write down these
laws in order to protect ourselves from
them then we're not going to have but
you know they uh they made some mistakes
there one of the mistakes was in the
Second Amendment because uh they
originally were going to say that uh
military
um being part of the military was not a
requirement to bearing arms because they
wanted to make sure that everyone had
the right to keep and bear arms
regardless of military service or
otherwise but they were scared that it
would be used as a legal a legal
argument to end conscription which was
which was a necessity at the time so
they said okay we'll just take that
language out
here we are yeah the the militia right
it is right so like uh George Mason
George Washington's hunting buddy had
something to say about that he said
specifically in the Constitutional
Convention when they were asked about
what it meant uh I asked sir what is the
militia it is the whole of the people
minus a few public officials yeah and
that right there ought to be enough to
tell you it was 17 articles approved by
the house August 24 1789 and uh I think
the first was specifically about 35
000 people per representative and you
know they but how fascinating to have a
paradox like that right if you're an
anti-federalist you say I don't think
the Constitution should be written I
don't think laws should be written down
at all but legal positivists who were
the federalists said well we believe the
laws need to be written down and the
Anti-Federalists knowing that they were
not a majority have to say let's okay
we'll write down some laws just to make
sure that we're protecting ourselves let
me read the original Second Amendment
which was called the fifth article a
well-regulated militia composed of the
body of the people being the best secure
of a free state the right of the people
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed but no one religiously
scrupulous of bearing arms shall be
compelled to render military service in
person and they were like okay hold on
there a minute we have conscription we
should probably get rid of that and thus
we ended up with the Fourth Article they
condense some the uh uh I think the
third and the fourth articles are both
the first uh the third and the fourth
are both the First Amendment and it got
they got combined into one an important
an important word in there too is well
regulated because the Liberals seize on
that of course with regulations but in
the late 1700s to be well regular meant
that you were a good shot right not to
be controlled but that you had
self-control it would well it meant a
variety of things it just it meant well
functional a a functional militia it
means your weapons work it means you
have boots it means you know what you're
doing right and but if you are well
regular that man that you were a good
shot but the funny thing is now people
don't understand language changes
actually not I think the left very very
much understands language changes and
then if they can change the
understanding of a word they can change
the law like changing the definition of
woman all just undermines completely the
uh Civil Rights Act of 1960. I think
it's 64. was it 67 uh I'm specifically
referring to I think Title IX or
whatever that protected women's rights
if you change the definition of woman to
a social construct then you delete from
the law books women's protections under
the law or the definition of vaccine
that's another one that of course also
changed definitions there's a lot of
changing definitions in this kind of new
orwellian word play that I think a lot
of people are playing into because they
understand that if you're able to change
the meaning of things you're able to
manipulate them in your own favor and
the people who control a lot of the
language also of course do do this with
big texts you want to know one of the
best amendments though it's that uh what
is it in suits at common law where the
value in controversy shall exceed twenty
dollars the right of a trial by Jerry
shall be preserved and no fact Tried by
a jury shall be otherwise re-examined in
any Court of the United States then
according to the rules of the common law
20 bucks that's a lot of money back then
I know it's like the National Firearms
Act when they first pass they they're
like 200 to buy Atomic gun and like
nobody will be able to afford that back
then they couldn't afford it now it's
like oh 200 so that you can get yourself
I just want to point out I love that
that point as the Federal Reserve
backfired horribly on the gun troll
people yeah uh Sam Adams how strangely
will the tools of a tyrant pervert the
plain meanings of words tyrants have
always used language to pervert the
plain meanings of words to turn it
around to their advantage and that's
exactly what the left does with the
Second Amendment
you were talking about uh the Paradox of
an assault the rifle wanting to be left
alone or what the Anti-Federalists
saying we don't want laws we don't need
these laws so why write them down but
then they had to write down laws to
protect their ability to not have to
live it's kind of like libertarianism in
general they want to be left alone but
in order to do that you have to create
laws that guarantee your ability to be
left alone correct that's yeah and
that's why I don't Venture into the
anarchist thing that and they want to
sell heroin to five-year-olds
is anarchism like a sect of
libertarianism of course like extremists
well oh no an anarchists I agree with a
lot of what they have to say just you
know not the heroine Anarchy means
without Authority yeah that seems like
an extreme position no rulers yeah
because you without a federal Authority
or without some sort of homework really
all that experience you make me stand up
for the anarchist tonight yeah
exists all around us in many ways I mean
the free market itself is anarchy the
black market itself is anarchy Anarchy
is all around us and you know in nature
and in many ways the internet to some
degree at least it was you know it was
very anarchic yeah yeah but it doesn't
doesn't mean without order but let's be
real I mean there's too many people and
somebody's got to work at McDonald's
right
yeah the world needs ditch diggers too
our friends so yeah but you made a good
point you know majority of Our Lives is
without central controllers is without
government and things you know figure
themselves out you know things don't go
chaotic things don't go crazy there's
even entire populations in Mexico but in
entire cities that got rid of their
governments and they're living a life
that that's a lot more peaceful than it
was with the government this is
specifically the city of Chiran uh tens
of thousands of people living peacefully
together and when they got rid of the
government they also got rid of the drug
cartels they also got rid of the police
I understand but if if people really get
rid of government then how do I exploit
them to steal from them
the free market as Anarchy I don't agree
because I think that it's the people
with all the money or the richest that
are controlling the market and deciding
especially the banking Bank of
international seven but but
they're rich because the government gave
them an upper hand because they gave
them an advantage they made sure that
companies got got you know in a
situation that an average person
couldn't get into and this is why we
have such big monopolies when it comes
to Big corporations hate free markets
they hate capital and they want more
taxes Mark Zuckerberg is the biggest
advocate for regulating social media why
because he knows that he's gonna go he's
gonna write the law the Auto industry
and the banks should have collapsed and
that something could have emerged in
their way to to fill the hole and it
would have functioned better but instead
the government the government intervened
they they printed money that diluted our
savings to prop up failures and we could
have had a better fall proof system that
actually worked to everyone's benefit
but we don't have that we have another
system that's going to collapse soon and
impact everyone that much more more
negatively because we keep properly up
and being welfare Queens to the
corporations here but the heart of the
evil at this is always the Federal
Reserve when we lost the control over
the power of money that is when we lost
our freedoms because money was always
was not a creation of governments
initially right we we had money before
we had government
it was always a voluntary means of
exchange but once we once we created
this public private Venture in the
Federal Reserve we gave away all of our
autonomy because it is the power to
print the power to print is the power to
destroy the power to print is the power
to control the power to print is it's
the central power over all of us the
Federal Reserve is to me the issue I
know that you know we have other issues
education and things like that but
ending the Federal Reserve would
probably be the greatest most
revolutionary Liberation liberating act
in in American history we've done it
twice I agree and we need to do it then
they put Jackson on the 20. yeah I agree
it's a problem late 1800s the Free
banking era the Scottish Free banking
era the the monetary Anarchy of the not
so wild west of the late 1800s in Grover
Cleveland it was a Gilded Age they call
it the age of Robert Barry Prosperity
but it was the Gilded Age it was a
golden era of American History it wasn't
it was left once it was it wasn't free
it was still you were still run by
robber barons Vanderbilt controlled he
decided if New York was going to get
food or not and that was so we had to
create antitrust laws and we needed
government because a a economy absent of
government is chaos and whoever's Born
Into the money controls the economy
oh if I had another hour and a half to
go into this uh they call them Robert
Barons I prefer to think that of them as
benevolent philanthropists actually
these men did so not only did they do
philanthropy with the money that they
had and they're still buildings you know
to car you know Carnegie in New York to
these Great Men of our society but you
know you shouldn't tarnish their their
image by believing the leftist
histrionics on this because this was a
great time of American Prosperity right
the tail end of the Industrial
Revolution and the height of the
Progressive Era as it came into the to
the late 1800s the early 1900s was one
of the greatest periods of American
History it was when we had one of the
freest immigration systems sorry
trumpers but it was it was a time of
American free market capitalism
freewheeling free market capital is in
the best place the best uh resources
that you can get on this would be the
not so wild west you can get that from
mises and you can also read
um
on the Great Depression you want to go
to fee.org Foundation for economic
education fee.org and the myths uh read
the myths of the Great Depression
because we used to have recessions and
and we used to have bankruptcies banks
used to go bankrupt if a bank was
issuing funny money or phony money doing
the Federal Reserve is doing they would
go bankrupt yeah it used to mean
something right and you'd have
liquidation and you have competition you
know why do we have Banks One Bank
setting the interest rate for the entire
country we're all suffering you know I
was talking to my old Sensei down in Old
Town uh he wants to buy a dojo because
he's getting forced out of his he's
getting forced out of his dojo and they
can't because the interest rates and
what they are but that's one small group
of of central Bankers deciding that but
you could have competition you could
actually have a money market account
that you would make money off of if we
didn't have a monopoly power but it's
the it's the Communist Revolution that
has taken over in this country we have
instituted not only we Institute the
planks The Communist Manifesto but we've
also instituted the German Workers you
know party of the 90 20s I won't say
their name we've instituted a lot of
their planks as well here but the it is
the control of money and credit that is
the that it is the evil Insidious power
that controls us all and prevents us
from really instituting the kind of free
market capitalism that would lift those
people that you're talking about out of
poverty they would have more options
they didn't like a bank they would be
able to go down the bank next door Bank
of America couldn't cancel or you know
JP Morgan Chase couldn't cancel no no
let's let's talk about war
uh let's say we get a decentralized very
anarchic system not not completely maybe
it's very very libertarian
um banks are failing and then new ones
are emerging what about say communist
China very very centralized very
authoritarian very expansionist
we ignore it what happens when a Soviet
block or communist Chinese Communist
party style thing starts creating a
unipolar world under their footprint
uh do you want to let me answer that
yeah okay yeah so so uh you know
communism you know has shown that in the
short term it can't have power and it
can't have strength right but capitalism
has won out in the long term the the
mistakes that the neoconservatives made
the people under Bill Buckley and Ronald
Reagan is that they believe that in
order to beat communism that we had to
adopt a tenants in planks of Communism
right they the the what was the Space
Race and the missile or is the arms race
between the United States and Russia
this was the belief they they believed
that capitalism had failed to provide
the United States with the type of
military strength that was necessary to
defeat communism but if you look at any
economic measure of Russia it wasn't
necessarily the spending on the space
race or on the arms race that bankrupted
Russia Russia was failing on its own
accord and it was a potemkin Villages
that were all across Russia you know for
decades you know their economy was
always on the verge of collapse now the
neoconservatives thought that by
spending more that they would tip them
over they ended up being right but I
wouldn't say that one unnecessarily one
correct fact doesn't prove an entire
Theory you know free market capitalism
is it a perfect system no is it a better
system than communism by any standard or
measure so so can communism show at
strength in the short term sure you know
if you force people it's like you know
Mussolini got the trains running on time
but where did he end up right hanging in
you know hanging alongside his yeah
it doesn't end well for you specifically
also when you look at China A lot of
people are saying look at all the
centralization look how you know Justin
Trudeau is like it's amazing how they
could control their economy
at at a what do you say exactly I forgot
the exact time he like he admired the
fact that they had so much control over
their economy yeah yeah you can sit on
the throne of bayonets but not for long
but but at the same time we have to
understand China's dealing with their
own unique problems even though Justin
Trudeau is looking at them like yeah
this is great this is awesome this is
this is amazing Bill Gates is
complimenting them they're still dealing
with a major housing crisis with the
major infrastructure prices a major
national resource uh crisis and their
current population crisis a currency
crisis and and their society is
literally at the brink of of collapse
because of the centralization and not
allowing individuals to be free and
creative and to solve the problems that
the central controllers are create are
creating so again it's all good today it
all comes down to one thing though
government is completely irrelevant with
culture so if you had uh let me tell you
you want to know how communism could
work if every single person every single
person within your country doesn't mean
communist government
agreed ideologically on the core
principles and tenants and and ideology
so let's say you had let's say you have
a million fundamentalist Christians who
all follow the Bible to the T defer to
their religious Scholars and theologians
for advice you are going to function
very very well but the only problem is
that's idealistic not realistic so
invariably what happens is Communists
say we can do it as long as everyone
just follows the rules and then someone
comes in and says but Premier 17 of the
population won't I have an idea let's
kill them yeah and then that's what you
end up getting the psychotic
authoritarian dictatorship you will
never achieve 100
ideological Conformity so there needs to
be a system I think we've done a really
great job in the United States of
allowing people of different ideas to
kind of come together but there is an
outer limit at a certain point you
spread so thin you end up with activists
defending conservative Islam in the same
breath as lgbtq education and then you
end up with protests between those
groups who are completely at odds with
each other at a certain point ideologies
cannot function under the same umbrella
without conflict without fighting yeah
we need more umbrellas that's for sure
like this one person represents 70 000
people 700 700 000 people 700 either way
the number's insane one person
represents themselves I can't represent
Luke effectively there's no way one of
the main reasons we're facing such big
problems here in the United States is
because of the centralization is because
of this banking system because of all
the people saying I am on top of the
government I have all this power I have
all this influence it's all for me me me
me me the individual can't solve their
problems because there's too much
regulations there's too much taxes
there's too much bureaucracy in the way
standing between the monopolies that are
being propped up by the federal
government because normally people would
say hey I don't want to be banking at
JPMorgan Chase that's why financing
Jeffrey Epstein hey I don't want you to
be participating in this larger system I
want another system that works for me
better and doesn't create more problems
but now we have a lot of problems
because of that sense so here's another
Paradox For You Luke and I wonder what
you think about this right so Ian you
know talked about the the representation
right one person representing 700 000
people right so in order to help aid
decentralization should we increase the
House of Representative size in order so
that people are more represented a fewer
amount of people per representative do
you think it's a good idea would that
actually help our Liberty by sending
more Congress people to Washington I
haven't thought about it in a long-term
perspective automatically my knee-jerk
reaction is hell no no no no no no no I
don't know any of that but but I haven't
thought about the long-term consequences
and it's a big hypothetical well well
here's here's something right if I think
we would have what like 7 000 members of
Congress if we scaled for population so
if more bureaucrats isn't going to do it
what if we whittled everything down down
to a lower to a smaller and smaller
number until maybe there was like one
person who just ran things for us and
then it's having to deal with elections
we just like their kids took over once
they died and then that family could
just deal with the response
we'd end up with Meghan Markle I think
but what if I got a better idea what if
we we create an idea of government that
that is called a representative a
democracy but in reality secret
corporations behind the scenes and
bankers really control all the shots and
and we we give people uh this pretend
ability that that they actually have a
voice and they actually that their vote
actually matters and then actually we
just do whatever the hell we want which
is exactly what the hell is happening
right now this was the plutonomy report
that we talked about a little while ago
came out a long time ago that basically
powerful interests control the economy
and the government and the opinion of
the public is meaningless they did a
study they found something like if
public opinion is like 100 in favor of
an idea it won't matter about the bill
being passed it's only when 60 of like
the wealthiest individuals support an
idea does it become law exactly and it's
all a scam and when you look at what the
government's doing right now they're not
upholding the Constitution they're doing
whatever they want they're taking Brute
Force anyone standing in their way they
either get thrown in jail they get
audited by the IRS or they get totally
screwed over where they don't even have
the ability to speak on social media
another Paradox though but Tim you've
identified something there when you talk
about when sixty percent of the wealthy
and the powerful people have an idea
then only and only then can become law I
mean wasn't the Constitutional
Convention just the wealthy Elites of
the United States gathering together in
secret putting together a document that
would govern all of us yes and here's
the best part in some of these State
conventions they weren't even
legitimately elected by the state it was
people in the state who agreed with
Independence who elected someone to go
down and the people who aren't in favor
of it had no idea so it is fascinating
but you'll you know look
if uh constitution of No Authority right
Luke I mean it was Plato that you know
um the penalty for failing to be
involved in politics is to be ruled by
the ignorant or something by your
inferior by your inferiors so for the
people who cared and paid attention and
were saying we need to fight this
problem and they got active and they set
the standard well then good for them
that's the people who fight the people
who participate and that's what our
governor really was supposed to be right
and that's why we have an electoral
college you know have you ever been an
elector if any of you ever been electors
so so I I went through the process to
become an elector for Ron Paul in New
York and you have to go through a series
of processes in order to actually become
a person who is going to be allowed to
vote and I like that right so the
Democrats talk about you know oh we need
to reduce barriers to voting I don't
agree with that I like the idea that the
people who show up to vote on issues are
the most informed they're the most
educated they're the most involved the
the people who only show up to vote once
every four years are not dictating to
the rest of us how things should be you
should have to show up at Council
meetings you should have to put your
name down on a piece of paper and
government should go to those who show
up yeah
service guarantee citizenship
I I'm not entirely opposed to that I'm
not entirely opposed to the idea that
being able to govern that you have to
participate or perform some form of
public you're familiar with Starship
Troopers
the only good bug is a dead bug but I
think the idea is actually very much
worth exploring I wouldn't say I'm
definitive on it the idea that service
guarantees citizenship basically
everybody gets full constitutional
rights but if you want to vote in the
system you have to have provided some
kind of service be it community service
military service contribute just
contribute yeah so a lot of people think
that phrase means military no no it
means you could be like a lifeguard it's
like you're a part of the system to help
make it work you can vote but if you're
a knowledgeable police right you know
and if you're not involved in it why
would you be voting on what everyone
else is doing right yeah you know so I
think that's interesting because right
now one of the problems we have is that
Democrats absolutely rely on stupid
people and exploiting stupid people
Republicans uh for a while did too the
unit party was one one big machine that
exploited the stupidity of the entire
country ignorance ignorant people
ignorant people definitely a better way
to phrase it
um now you have
a rising faction the uh the children of
the Ron Paul Love Revolution and others
who are paying attention questioning
what the government is doing demanding
answers as to why it's being done in
their name wondering why their money is
going and this creating a very serious
problem for you in a party but it's also
creating a new faction of people who are
like hey maybe we shouldn't be invading
foreign countries wasting our money on
this stuff maybe we should focus on
ourselves but then you very much have
what the Democrat Party goes after and
that's people who don't pay attention
and just do whatever they they're told
what makes them fit in Luke you must
have really loved watching the Maga
trumpers destroy the neocons and seeing
the new Republican party because when
you and I were activists for Ron Paul in
New York City together from around 2008
to 2012. our greatest enemy were the
neo-conservatives we were fighting
against the bushy Republicans we were
fighting against the David frums we were
fighting against the bill crystals and
then Donald Trump came in and
accomplished what you and I had been
trying to do for years and and now we
have the situation where maybe we don't
agree always with the the stated aims of
Mega Trump you know the populism does
lend itself to a form of Republican
socialism that you and I might not agree
with but but isn't it fascinating now
that like our opponents have shifted and
that no longer the the neocons are a
shadow of what they once were we're no
longer worried about right and they
joined the Democratic party yes where
they came from where they came from the
neoconservatives came in from the in the
1970s I'm not going to say I wasn't
entertained
but any kind of political infighting is
always great to me because when
politicians and governments are fighting
each other they're not fighting the
people at which they're usually doing
but at the same time you know Donald
Trump did put in John Bolton John Bolton
was also that key person that we were
protesting against and standing up
against because his his Viewpoint was
absolutely insane uh but but to bring
them back to the point that we were just
discussing here you know we look at
history 500 years ago and we look at
people and we kind of think that they
were backwards because they had a king
in the Monarch I think from 500 years
from now we're going to be looking back
at the people now and be like these
idiots believed in the president scam I
can't believe they they allowed them to
get away with this and didn't have
personal responsibility and lived their
lives
here's what's going to happen in 100
years we're all going to be brain Linked
In neuralink in Mark Zuckerberg Zucker
verse and then we're all going to be
like everything has always been good yes
Mark Zuckerberg has always been our
leader it's amazing that's a little bit
of a negative visualization I like to be
a little bit more of a uh you know
positive positive person and and I think
we do dictate our own reality with some
of the thoughts that we create in our
minds and we should always be positive
all right let me let me as much as we
can then it's a hundred years we're all
floating around in our anti-grav boots
with our brains connected to the neural
link praising the Zucker verse when a
ragtag group of rootkowskians break into
the main server farm for the Zucker
verse and take out this the the main
Central server and all of a sudden
everyone just goes ah I'm free and then
all of the children of the lucridkowski
Revolution are like a great man brought
us here and they're holding a picture of
an old man Luke smiling and giving a
thumbs up stop with the fighting
peaceful resolution and learn to respect
other people and not hurt them and not
steal from them all right if we just had
those two principles life would be
amazing all right then here's what it is
it's a hundred years everyone's floating
around their Zucker verse programs and
then a redkowski and peacefully walks in
and delivers a crystal and there's a and
the zuckerbergians are like what's this
and then also the pulse of energy goes
out shutting the servers down everyone
says you've awakened us Luke you have
saved us and we are grateful and
everyone hugs listen the Zucker lizards
are not going to be in charge here okay
for Humanity usually prevails and if you
look at human history we have been
making progressions progressions towards
more Liberty more freedom more
decentralization I think we need more of
it and I think when we have that we have
human progression Luke do you find
yourself now like more in agreement and
happier that the more Pat buchananite
style Republicans the populist
Republicans are more of the uh of the
majority of the Republican Party versus
the New York conservatives knowing that
knowing knowing that neoconservatives
tend to agree with us Libertarians on
things like the war on drugs and on
immigration and that the uh that the
Maga Trump like National conservative
types do not agree with us on
immigration they do not agree with us on
the war on drugs and social issues and
things like that do you find yourself
you know happier now that the more
buchananites or the the up search that
you can work with them more than like
the romneyites or the personally I'm not
a fan of any politician I think all of
them should have their feet to the fire
I'm critical of all of them and during
the Trump era I was very critical of
them and just like I am anyone in power
because I think anyone in power always
deserves criticism criticism
um and and I think the more we do that
the better uh government you're a market
fundamentalist right like like I am
right so we both believe in like the the
free market the unfettered free market
power in my point of views I'm a lot
more flexible especially when it comes
to a case-by-case basis right because I
think it all depends on the current
circumstances because when you look at
immigration you've also gotta factor in
welfare you also have to factor in you
know the tax system we have right now
that's taken our money away and
incentivize it so then we can't legalize
drugs because people might use welfare
money to buy drugs then right no that's
a very you know that's very kind of
layered argument there buddy
I'm saying everything's by by Case by
case basis but at the end of the day I I
think I always lean towards less
government less regulations less taxes
less centralization less bureaucracy
less welfare and drug laws I'm just
fascinated by the discussion on the
right that is you know the abandonment
of free market principles and the
advocacy of many of these National
concerns it just comes down to one thing
the right needs to understand the laws
are meaningless the culture is
everything and the example example I'd
like to give is that you can have a law
on the book like
um you can't protest at an abortion
clinic and you can have another law in
the book you can't protest at a judge's
house but if your culture only enforces
one thing the laws are irrelevant what
are we seeing we had I think 12 or 11 or
12 pro-lifers arrested for protesting at
an abortion clinic none of the
protesters protesters at the judge's
house got arrested that's a cultural
problem I don't think that the laws are
irrelevant but I think I would agree
with you that the culture is more
important I do think that the culture
war is it needs to happen and we need to
be at the foreign
if this whole country all completely
agreed on cultural issues you would have
no crime yeah true but but because they
don't know about that I'm not I don't
mean quite literally I mean for the most
part crime would be dramatically gone
like it would be it would be it would be
minuscule there would be acts of
desperation but the issue is we don't
view each other as neighbors and it's a
question of the the morals of the
culture if this if this entire country
was staunchly Christian and conservative
like many of the more libertarian Maga
type Christians then there'd probably be
no crime everybody would be more fear
lesser crime but to an extreme degree
yes definitely so when you when you when
if you I'll put it without law how Jack
caused a crime well well it's not just
that if if everybody held the ideology
of Jack pesobic and his family you're
going to have very little crime if
anything people are going to work and
they're going to try to find ways to get
along I'm interested in Jack I'm using
you as an example yeah but if Jack was
in desperate poverty and his family was
suffering and starving his children were
starving he'd probably steal food for
his kids no because Jack's ideology is
communal giving and support he's in a
position to be able to have that and
that means this is my point if everybody
agreed on how it should work then you
have a functioning homogenized system
I'm saying it's impossible so but but
the point is Utopia when right when when
this country has a has a culture that to
a great degree like 80 percent is held
by everybody then you're going to have
things where people are all basically in
agreement and not arguing with each
other you're not gonna have culture
conflict you're not going to have
religious fighting and things like that
because everyone we do have to get rid
of other people's religions that would
be a problem but but get rid of if it if
we're in a place like we are now which
is the challenge we face what I'm saying
is a long long time ago when you had
very small tribes they all agree with
each other as you scale them and get
bigger and add different ideologies to
the mix you start getting internal
conflict we have what's called culture
species conflict it's culture shock this
is global culture shock this is what
happens when cultures mingle and it all
happened within 20 between like 20 2007
to 2022 we're experiencing this massive
Consciousness shock God yes you're so
smartphones yeah no you're right you're
coming to conflict with people you know
just by you know virtue of being around
them and hearing their views right and
it people struggle with that it's
difficult and when I came into DC from
Missouri the other day it was shocking
to go from you know rural Missouri to
Washington DC and to be into this
culture you have to shift your attitudes
you've got to get along with these
people and interact with them in a way
that they want to interact when you go
and buy something at a checkout line
here you better move fast you better
make your decision right away but in
Missouri you can take your time you can
you can hear what they have to say right
and you have to when you go to Missouri
you better get along with how
missourians are so you're you're
absolutely correct that this is an an
international culture shock the internet
has facilitated it right mass
communication but also just Mass travel
you know 100 years ago it wasn't easy
for people of our you know of modest
means to be able to get in a Airbus and
go around the world and travel together
so we are experiencing the long-term
kind of ramifications of you know these
face-to-face interactions that were not
possible before right like because what
Tim was saying with the tribes that all
lived together they were homogeneous
they all live together but we live in a
heterogeneous world and we've all got to
figure out a way to live together not
just here in the United States between
ourselves but internationally as well
and that's a problem that's why there's
conflict and that's why there's war I
don't I don't believe in Utopia right
that literally means no place yeah right
so I don't think that there will ever be
that situation that there's no crime and
I I don't even believe that like you
said if most people you know agreed on
everything and had Jack postovic's views
that there would be no crime I think you
know mental illness and other factors
of passion cheating but hold on
obviously I'm not saying there's not
going to be deviation and people I'm
saying there's a lot of conflict bred by
people who don't View each other as
neighbors right they don't view each
other they don't agree on morality there
are people who believe children should
get sex changes and people who don't
yeah if everybody agreed on the core
issues then your conflict would be much
would be minimal they would exist
obviously because mental illness exists
and poverty exists of course right I
just think people probably people are
rebellious people when like when I
people just like oppositional Defiance
disorder like when when you're this I
want to be that right I think that
that's you know that that's kind of like
our childish nature right but there's
something yeah there's something to the
something to that and a new culture
would develop you'd never be able to
create a real monoculture because people
want to create a culture within a
culture it's the reason why Christian
different sects of Christianity exist
right because and because the of the
telephone game everybody's going to
interpret ever you know what they hear
the it doesn't matter we have more
sources and availability of information
and yet we have more misunderstanding
and dis you know disunderstanding that's
because you have evil people true look
and if you you have people who
intentionally lie to gain political
power they won't have have conversations
they won't engage they claim to be
socialist but they're by Mansions things
like that and there's a lot of
sociopaths and where do sociopaths
usually gather at the largest positions
of power so I think this is why we have
we need to have less positions of power
over everyone's life because at the end
of the day the government is looking at
people and saying you the people can't
be trusted what what's the government
made of the people of individuals who
are not perfect who shouldn't be trusted
and of course a high level of sociopaths
which are located in Washington DC more
per capita than anywhere else in
Washington DC are the ones controlling
your life telling you what to do no I
don't want the Paradox I have is I don't
like uh representative democracy very
much because you can't represent me
properly I need to represent myself but
I'm also a concerned with mob mentality
and MOB rule because we don't have
people in charge then the mob can switch
on a dime from an internet video and go
vote some crazy new murder and so like
at what point do you have to or should
you give over your authority to someone
else right I don't think he I don't
think he should I think he should be
personally responsible for yourself and
I think Grandma look at things falling
let him always stay at the farm to make
sure that nobody steals her chickens so
she's going to have to Grant authority
to the local police to be able to do
something like that for you people are
going to divest their authority to
someone else and there's always going to
be that you know transfer of power from
one person to another and that's going
to happen voluntarily right you know the
more voluntarily the better but I wanted
to tell you a brief story about the
early days of the internet some of you
probably know this I bet you Tim you
will but talk about misinformation and
disinformation they found that the way
to prevent people from falling for fake
news in the early days of Internet
forums was to actually create more fake
news and I wish that this would get more
publicity because it was talk they wrote
about it in Wired Magazine because
people would post when they would ask
questions about how to you know install
their sound card or modem or whatever
put the wrong you're saying put the
wrong the wrong thing down they would
deliberately give the wrong information
they would flood the boards with
disinformation because what they found
was that the more disinformation the
more more people adjusted to to realize
I need to be skeptical and now I know
that that I need to check my information
before I do it because I know that
that's out there that's why I don't
believe in Internet censorship that's
why I think Alex Jones should be on
Twitter that's why I think you know
anybody all more information is good
even disinformation because people will
naturally make mistakes and that's why
they're getting rid of it I think that
that issue maybe diminishing return
because if a parent's like I'm lying to
you because I love you to teach you how
to learn how to deal with lies like like
parents sucks like parents who tell
their kids Santa's real
and then eventually the kid learns
through being mocked by their friends
that their parents lied to them and it
made him a laughing stock yeah that
happened to me that and it didn't help I
hear a lot of these I hear a lot of
these stories where parents you know
tell their kids Easter Bunny Tooth Fairy
Santa then they go to school and
eventually what happens is one group of
parents determines five is too old to
believe in Santa another parent says
seven is too old that six-year-old then
meets the five the other six-year-old
and and they start making fun of him
saying you're so dumb you believe in
Santa we learned that a long time ago
the kid gets mad it's my parents lied to
me and then they're gonna be like my
parents play tricks on me for reasons I
don't understand so you got to be
careful about these these Traditions too
I see your point about learning how to
discern between truth and lies though if
you're never lied to then how will you
know if someone's lying to you or how
even though lies can happen well it's
like one uh amazing Randy James Randy
yeah he used to participate in
experiments where they not experiments
but they would they would actually go to
tribes in Africa and and deliberately
trick them pretend to be witch doctors
and they did it in order to show them
that hey the medicine men who come
through here are just trying to screw
you over so they showed them the tricks
of the trade remember when they used to
go and they would look like they were
pulling out some evil from their guts
and things like that they would go and
show do these magic shows and Penn and
Teller did this all the time in order to
to show that they were being fooled I
mean Penn and Teller are probably most
famous for that but I think that there's
value in that in deliberately deceiving
in order to inform and educate I think
that that's a legitimate strategy but I
also think that it happens by default
that's why you know disinformation
online misinformation conspiracy
theories whatever it is everything
should be allowed as long you know other
than perhaps threats of direct violence
I'm going to kill you like if Ethan had
said no I'm going to put you in the
camps or whatever too on this day
when you specify a day and a time in a
place yeah exactly but otherwise it
should be anything goes in order that
people might be able I don't think Ethan
should be banned should be suspended for
being a dick I think I think it should
be allowed right everybody's being a
dick though but you know it's it's and
I'm not even that I'm not even if he was
trying to be funny but he failed I think
he was trying to be funny but it wasn't
fun I understand the point he was trying
to make I think it was crude and I think
he should be allowed to say it and it's
and and look I gotta be honest like I
wouldn't boycott him over it I wouldn't
cancel him over it I'd be like come on
bro and then I'd move on with my life
there's some weird people out there My
Buddy Joe who's with me tonight was
telling me about this Jewish friend of
his and she's like I think Jews should
be sent off and and and he's like well
you are a Jew and she's like and I would
be I would round them all up and I would
be the last one to go she's like okay
I'm not kidding you probably know who
this person is but I won't say the name
but I'm just saying that like you know
you ought to be able to post something
like that you ought to be able to say
something
yeah well the best thing here's the
thing the best way for us to know who
the crazy people are is to let them say
yeah yeah how are we supposed to know
who's Crazy who's who's a racist I want
to know I want to know let me tell you
the bake the cake thing let me tell you
let me tell you we want to know who the
homophobes are let me tell you a story
exactly I went to Europe and I was at a
protest I think it was for uh count
dankula or something and I was having a
conversation about an individual in the
United States and I said this individual
has said racial slurs before and this
British no he hasn't and then I was like
it was a passive comment and I was like
yeah you know when the dude goes on his
show and starts saying X Y and Z it's
kind of like you're going too far and
this guy goes he never said that and I
was like yeah he did I was like it was
like a big thing they made a bunch of
stories about it they said he was
pushing the boundaries and he goes BS
you made that up and I grabbed my phone
I'm in London and I Google it nothing
comes up and I'm like where's the story
I scrolled on the bottom and it said due
to you know offensive posts or whatever
they've been removed and I'm like yo I
can't even prove that this guy said
these things and this guy thinks I'm
lying about it exactly that's exactly
insane the censorship actually helped
the race that's happened to me before
too yeah because they they pull down
post and I'm like hey this guy was lying
about this he said this back in the day
and then they went and they pulled it
and it's like damn I can't prove that
this is this information think about
this real quick Alex Jones when he got
banned they didn't just silence him they
deleted everything he ever said on the
platform so he can't even comply with
Discovery right now but a bigger point
to censorship it helps out radical
voices it makes people more radical more
extreme than they would normally be
because now to speak they have to go to
the Far Corners of the internet where
all of this is is a safe space and they
just keep pushing and pushing uh you
know the the envelope creating niches to
the craziest point that they can if you
really want to dispel it you counter it
there's bad information good information
governments need enemies and that's why
the whole like domestic terrorist white
supremacist thing right they fashion it
right that's why Ray Epps right they
they fashion it they have to fabricate
it if they can't if if it doesn't come
naturally it's like racism right the
demand for racism has outstripped the
supply for sure
whether or not it becomes an enemy is
kind of like we don't want it to become
an enemy that's why we are our own
opposition we're going to go to super
chats all right if you haven't already
would you kindly smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends become a member
at timcast.com to support our work
directly I hope you're enjoying your
Friday night let's read what we got Josh
says Alex Jones has to colonize Mars
then gift it to the families it's the
only way or or hold on hear me out Alex
Jones could conquer France oh my God and
then turn it over you know you can just
have friends
Canada you've got to take Canada mimic
says nonsense if he hasn't ordered to
pay at least 11 d17 gazillion dollars
there's obviously no justice in this
country he did an interview with ping
trip and which looks like a fake
interview it's pretty well done and he
was like why didn't they just do it
quadrillion man I need another he didn't
say man that was me quadrillion what are
they waiting why why Maximus Rita said
you defend Ethan's threat not Kanye
saying r word I think both were crass
and both should be allowed it's not hard
yeah it's free speech yeah Kanye I
actually I think what Kanye said was
funny but it was crass but I also think
it's going to get a lot of young people
to vote against Democrats yeah did you
see Pierce's face right after that
that's surprising yeah all right scruffy
Knight says the gay cake issue mentioned
last night is not complicated cakes are
a works of art especially custom you
cannot compel someone to make a work of
art especially with politics opposed by
the artist simple as that I never liked
that argument just because it's sort of
it it legitimizes the law like where the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 is titled II
you know attempts to make these
delineations right in terms of
discrimination because I really do think
that it should just simply be a private
property issue not that we need to get
into oh is this a work of art or that a
work of art because what you're doing
there is you're allowing the government
to start to you know to make the
delineation between what is art and what
is an art Raymond g Stanley Jr said as
Tim a year ago was members Meetup it was
a good time Luke went off on stage Ian
convinced me to be me and drop Turk
Longwell shout out to everyone who was
there you still owe me 13 for name tags
well maybe uh we'll do another members
meet up soon and uh we will get you back
that thirteen dollars let's do it I I
loved it it was a great energy it was
fun I remember I went on stage I was
just like ah I'm just screaming we
jammed to play some music people in the
comments are like Luke stop yelling I
never started yelling yeah
how crazy I could get AI says shirt idea
for Luke where is James Gordon Meek that
is crazy yeah where is that guy it's
kind of a theory into it it's kind of a
serious matter I don't know if I want a
profit off something like that I think
we need to make you know hold on make
the situation uh you know wait wait wait
wait hear me out it's James Gordon Meek
with Joe Biden with his hands over his
shoulder leaning him sniffing him and
James looking over like you know like
too early too early let's let's find him
first let's find out what happened to
him first before making any kind of
t-shirt please
well all right then
all right
idiosyncrasy Media Group says I was
inspired by you guys to make something
new for the last year I've been teaching
myself how to animate so I can animate
an original TV show it's called who
killed Mr Jones today we released the
theme song and launched a Kickstarter
for it nice cool
Kudos I had a joke I want to do with
Sheamus but but it was just too hard to
do and it was um Alex Jones and me you
know the song by Counting Crows Mr Jones
I know it well I was just like
tell each other fairy tales it's perfect
here's the problem the song is wild and
all over the place and I think I don't
know if Sheamus ever did it but like the
the uh writing lyrics to it was just
weird to try and sing because the song's
weird as it is I could definitely sing
it I know it very well go ahead right
now go uh
yeah sir damn
sure that's your hair girl Mr Jones
trucks up a conversation
computer just spazzed out on it that was
weird
it was me channeling God's spirit energy
and it'll keep happening and it'll keep
getting more powerful so be prepared get
a faraday cage not an imminent threat no
no I'm just letting you know ahead of
time oh
the life of Dee says isn't this against
the Eighth Amendment cruel and unusual
punishments
Ian singing
it was horrible yeah
okay
let's see Samuel Brooker says they
dignify Alex Jones by making him a
nation
that's right he has to pay the GDP of
France
I feel like they were definitely saying
that with the the finger next to their
mouth like this yeah doing the Dr Evil
says Tommy tampon says I want to be a
subscriber for 80 years Tim cast at one
thousand dollars a month but I heard Ian
was a conservative so I can't oh no
that's twice now wow wow that's a lot of
money there that's a lot of loss yeah
that's a couple million dollars right
there added to the totals
all right Teddy henkelman says yo Tim my
family and I are traveling to Arkansas
from Illinois for my lady's birthday we
decided to listen to you live can you
give Sarah a shout out shout out Sarah
thanks for watching the show we have a
chicken named Sarah
she's a good chicken she's a Brahma
happy birthday she got sick but she's
okay
we have more information on Roberto Jr's
mom Katarina she had cancer we were
worried it was Merrick's disease or
something it's called turns out it was
just typical old cancer took poor
Katarina at a very young age it was in
her egg sac and uh
you know sad story stress didn't jump by
the boys no I should say cancer
sometimes it happens man
um we got the chickens checked out like
everything's good the other chickens are
fine but you know she had uh one son I
think she only had one kid it's Roberto
Jr so we're really worried now and we're
gonna we're probably gonna We want to
make sure we don't lose her genetic line
so we got to make sure that Roberto Jr
has many children yeah he's got to be a
dad soon so we have to wait a little bit
because it's only October so we probably
have to wait until mid-December to start
incubating a batch of eggs but uh
Roberto Junior's gonna have a lot of
babies and then Katarina will live on
through her son
there you go chickens they'll live
forever
Aaron heiner says are you going to talk
about Steve Bannon being sent uh
sentenced to four months in prison man
we really just kind of went off right so
there's gonna be no way out of the
founding fathers tonight luckily we
didn't get into the roads it was close
man we should dude because that's what
the Vanderbilt problem of the robber
barons is he could just shut off access
from for to New York City he owned the
railroad right Luke are you going to go
as roads for Halloween I I could that's
a good I already have a costume
Jonathan lenneberg says 2.75 trillion is
more than double what Poland demands in
reparations from Germany's World War II
actions
yikes man
Brandon hampson says Robert Downey Jr
should come back to the MCU as the New
Black Panther
[Laughter]
I could see it
all right honkatonk says speaking from a
chill voting for Obama back in the day
Vibe The Establishment has evolved dudes
that is true yes it has
let's grab some more Super chats Paul
Sakura says O.J Simpson had to pay 33.5
million dollars for the deaths of two
people and Jones has to pay in the
hundreds of Millions for saying some
stuff this bad inflation man
explains it that explains it good one
Paul
Ian Kitty says how do I put in a uh put
in a bid on the flooring for the new
place I do tile lvp laminate hardwood
carpet will travel just give me a couch
to crash on I don't I don't we have a
guy uh unfortunately for Ian sorry we
have a guy who handles everything for us
he's a he's a he's a builder what kind
of floor is he gonna put in there I
don't like I don't know what they're
refers to we're talking about Freedom
stand yeah concrete
the the studio room is going to be a
carpeted floor like normal but the
ground floor is just going to be smooth
concrete I I don't know if we're going
to seal it I've been advised by the
skate park company not to seal it but I
love sealed ground so I'm kind of like
uh I like it when it's so slippery
you're slipping around why not sealed
just because slippery
no because when you're skating you spin
around like crazy it's hard to get a
grip but I I actually like it I like
being able to do like a backside flip
and then really fast or like YouTube by
spinning around yeah I love it yeah I
like it makes it and your board lasts
longer that's true so I'm like I don't I
don't know and and the concrete will
last way longer if we don't raise your
tail as fast nearly yeah exactly yeah
totally this guy's know what I'm talking
about I don't like it I can't hit the
punching bag it keeps like slipping all
the time you gotta get those rubber
shoes what do you mean yeah in the in
the park in the garage oh okay
probably leftover oil yeah for your cars
right so it is super slippery in there
though that is an issue so it's hyper
slick one thing we did was you put a can
of Coke and a mop bucket full of water
yeah yeah to mop it down and then you
get a little stick yeah we could do that
I mean I think Brett prefers it that way
and I don't skate in the garage all that
often I'm usually skating outside so you
got a punching bag in your garage yeah
you guys do martial arts in here yeah uh
ice skate this guy who fights I do
kickboxing dude let's do some let's
fight later yeah let's do it
yeah sanctioned event
uh and then uh you know the rest of us
will skate so you guys can we'll skate
around you you guys could do your
ballerina
will cybernaut says Ian you made a
mistake I love you please don't double
down that was in reference to the Ben
Shapiro thing
uh oh the Ethan Klein wanted to bond
with Ben yeah yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says I feel like
Biden now Ian just broke my brain
well it's not your fault why don't you
feel like fetterman is there a reason
why man John fetterman yeah I can't
believe people would consider voting for
that guy yeah me either
honestly some of the stuff that he says
I'm like all right it's not as bad as
the gop's making it out to be well did
you see the send me to Washington D.C to
fight I could to work for work yeah no
no he's definitely got the Biden
dementia thing going on but like some of
the criminal justice reforms that he's
proposing oh yeah it's like the GOP is
like oh he wants to release these people
who are non-violent criminals yeah but
he did he did advocate for convicted
murderers and now one guy is actually
being charged with murder again no I
know he's a Democrat so he's gonna you
know every once in a while but this crap
poops out I saw I saw cernovich uh
retweeted um something about Tim Ryan I
think it was cernovich forgive me if I'm
wrong uh Tim Ryan wanting to release
prisoners but then the first thing Ryan
brings up the only thing was getting
marijuana off this off schedule one and
then I was like okay well I agree with
that yeah like yeah I mean I'm not gonna
pretend to hate Tim Ryan because he's a
Democrat I think we should get marijuana
off schedule yeah that's always painful
because like the Republicans still hold
on to that stuff man oh yeah still
campaigning on that side it's like let's
hit that fight
lift the prohibition on marijuana it's
yeah as opposed to make it legal again
make it legal or lift the prohibition
it's not working and then they're like
oh then then next they're going to want
to legalize shrooms and we're like yes
yeah pretty much yes we do all right
mimic says to quote the great
philosopher from Animaniacs the brain
once said lies are just facts that
haven't been repeated enough yet oh
that's some dark stuff but that's
basically the the quote if you repeat a
lie enough it becomes effect
yeah I think man brain was dark
semi-fascists you know what I liked
about Pinky and the Brain though the
brain was a really evil little mouse but
he really did care for Pinky he did
that's true whenever pinky got really
hurt the brain would get really like sad
and scared and worried about his friend
even genocidal Maniacs have love that's
right I mean well I don't know did the
brain want to kill everybody she wanted
to you just want to rule the world
exactly it wasn't Genesis
he's not Bill Gates now come on
oh man Gillian Chapman says Jones shows
a precedent that true Americans will
need to do a lot peaceful fighting to
maintain our natural rights such as
voting this November 8th I love the show
I've been watching since 2019 when I was
shown the corruption head is corruption
indeed man yeah corruption indeed
okay what do we have here
Brian turistiniak says hey Tim big fan
here as much as I wanted to be true Joe
Biden was not booed at the game that was
a fake video officer Tatum proved it to
be false I like that you're factual so
the other day someone mentioned this to
me and I was looking at some videos
where I heard the booing and then I saw
that it was reported definitively by
several outlets and so I rolled with it
but um I've heard this more and more I
found a different video showing there
was no booing I'm not so I think it may
be it may be correct if the video was
fake
I just need to go in and and verify and
then I'll put an update on the video I
did from earlier in the week because
it's a fake video because yeah
mainstream Outlets had been reporting it
as fact yeah the New York Post ran it
saying Jill Biden booed I wonder if what
happened was she was booed but someone
made a fake video like enhancing the boo
exactly right or putting a fake boo over
it to make it sound really loud when it
was actually just like a marginal booing
right I think what ended up what ended
up happening was several outlets fact
checked it and said while it's true
people there probably were booing her
these videos aren't real and it's like
oh okay was anyone at the game in the
chat if anyone's there let us know maybe
let's grab some more super jets
Paul Blackman says I'm beginning to
think the reason why the rebels knew
about the second death star was because
James O'Keefe was able to get a
stormtrooper to talk he's great oh that
was that actually would be a really
great skill yeah he's gonna do some more
of that stuff like a Veritas like
infiltrates the Death Star they have
like a secret camera and then you have
like a stormtrooper silhouette being
like princess Raiders planning to blow
up
is Leia all sexy like getting the
Stormtrooper to talk yeah you have no
idea the amount of plants were gonna
blow up man
oh my God you guys are gonna attack the
Revel base on Hoth no and Ewoks are
disgusting little creatures
look and he's racist I gotta say like
Veritas could do a bunch of funny skits
like that'd be good yeah
project Veritas could do a Breaking Bad
Thing
all right
Hayden says the Constitution is divinely
inspired document it is a beautiful
social compact the social compact has
been violated by one side the
Constitution is not a suicide pact if
they use it against us or uh and for
their protection there is a massive
issue I would love to break this barrier
for them and us because I mean honestly
I'm with government for the People by
the people we're all involved in this
why can't we all just get along track
media only says Luke
local judges ignoring the Constitution
is exactly why you can appeal to the
Supreme Court if you divorce as it means
you lose that we've lost the balance and
divorce doesn't get that back that's
what I was trying to tell them track
media only there we go that's my boy
that's like one little argument over of
course the big centralized but with that
you have the Department of Education you
have the ATF you have you have the IRS
you want all of that or you want your
little little judges I think the judges
should be localized says the Erica says
the the Constitution has either
authorized the current form of
government that we have or been powers
to prevent it but I like to say that the
anarchist movement has either authorized
the form of government that we have or
been powerless to prevent it I don't
think so I think when we have small
individual actions like homeschooling uh
people arming themselves people making
their own food uh people become
independent that's actions of Anarchy
that that are promoted do push out
government and make the government
irrelevant because people don't need to
be dependent on government and make it
less uh you know dependent on everyone
else okay
Frank says minarchism is the best Ben
Franklin had it right the government
that governs best governs lease
I like the Reagan one what is it uh no
scarier phrase than I'm from the
government I'm here to help yes that's
my Halloween costume this year I got a
shirt that says that I'm here to help
yeah no it says government just
government and I'm gonna I'm gonna go
around that night and say I'm here to
help you really want to scare people
just walk around dressed up like an IRS
agent knock on the door and oh God we're
trick-or-treating costume yes that would
be the scariest thing for any adult
answering the door and you'll be like
I'm not trick-or-treating yes no no no
you could get my government shirt at my
AP for Liberty shop you can say I'm one
of the 87 000 new uh hires and I'm here
to talk to you about your finances
Oh no just kidding just kidding it's
Halloween were you scared it was scary
right you got to be practically scary
man I like the IRS thing though that's
good that would be really good good
costume
tangent says shout out to Ian after
countless hours of talking recognizing
that quote didn't sound like something
you'd say is amazing how passionately
you conveyed it feeling off was the
reason I dug into it tangent's the one
of course
yeah well the fact that you're like I
don't say the word folks yeah I don't I
don't use that word I don't like it
James Lindsay actually came on the show
and explained how it's like I don't know
if it's communist propaganda there's
it's like a it's like a seated into our
language somehow I don't know if Obama
did it intentionally what are you saying
about Sheamus
I'm not saying Sheamus is a racist no I
love Sheamus actually Anthony Jones says
Tim maybe the aliens have hope for
Humanity because of shows like this Ian
we need more info on radar manipulation
Luke love wearing my Emperor fouchy
shirt to Our Guest Rock Chalk Jayhawk
Goku
if you really want to learn about uh
radar manipulation look up talking
plasma and you might be able to find
something for military times niz
says Peterson has it totally backwards
Federalist oppose centralized power and
Hamilton was the worst he was the first
neocon along with Washington and Adams
the Constitution is objectively lacking
look where we are what the the fed the
Anti-Federalists were the ones who
opposed centralized power that's like
what it means yeah Anti-Federalist right
Anti-Federalists they were against the
central federal government they were
against the creation of the Constitution
the Federalists were the ones who wanted
to create the government I thought it
was the Anti-Federalists that wanted the
Bill of Rights yes but they didn't well
they didn't want the Bill of Rights they
wrote the Bill of Rights because they're
like we know that you guys are going to
write the Constitution and you're going
to write the laws we need to slip this
in here to make sure we still have
rights protected
Cal L says the founding fathers actually
give a blueprint on how to dismantle the
government without due process through
Invasion Step by Step the White House
announced on 9 12 they're using a tech
to do it what does that refer to yeah
more info please yeah I don't know I
think there's there's something missing
there
Christos aretico says as a Canadian in
Montreal I seconded the motion for
United States and provinces of America
uh c-a-u-s
of the great North American Republic
glory to timcast and friends have you
guys watched the um electric dreams
episode others kill all others you've
mentioned it noon it sounds awesome
watch it man you guys you're missing out
yeah electric dreams is it's on Amazon
but it's um like Philip K dick stories
and there's a an episode called kill all
others it's brilliantly done everyone
who watches this show would absolutely
love that episode there's a guy he's
chilling on on his couch watching the
debate and it's like a single candidate
running for office there's no there's no
you know a real election and she gets
asked by an interviewer like well you
know you know so tell me what are your
plans when you become the the president
and the candidate she's like well you
know first we need to totally gut these
schools because they're a huge problem
kill all others of course and then
obviously the economy is in serious
trouble and then he goes whoa whoa what
did she just say and then he plays it
over and she keeps saying like she says
it and then the interviewer go he's like
honey come in here listen to this and
the interview goes no whoa whoa that was
very controversial I can't believe you
would say that you want to gut the
schools now a lot of people and he's
like what's going on then he's asking
his people like his friends at work and
there's like only a few people there and
he's like can you believe she said that
they're like I don't know man I don't
watch that political stuff and then what
happens is as the time goes on he
eventually is like driving to work with
his wife and then he sees like people
chasing a woman who's screaming and
they're like get her she's an other he
sees an ad that says kill all others
he's on a train and then he sees
Billboards for it and then eventually
they're like why are you defending
others are you another and he's like no
I just don't understand why you're doing
it like he's another he's a and then you
know we see this happening it's such a
good episode tonight that sounds good
what's the show called electric dreams
from 2017 sci-fi yeah the whole season
was great I like that Philip K dick
stories but I think that was like the
last one I watched it and I was
flabbergasted they made it 10 episodes I
was like this this explains everything
that's going on exactly with cancel
culture and the woke left it's from a
book The Hanging stranger
it's good stuff man it's a good episode
edit it definitely check it out
yeah and the reason I brought it up was
because
um Christos mentioned Canada and
Montreal in the episode they live in
Mexican and it's the North American
unified body or whatever in Fallout 3 I
think like the in the Fallout story
didn't Canada and Mexico join the US
um I don't know I think I think like the
US may have annexed Canada or something
like that because they needed oil and
then China invades Alaska or something
aliens are attempting to take over he
tries to save everyone else but dies
trying to protect everyone in which one
well the book that it's based on
um well it's 12 different and it's an
anthology series
right so you may be referring electric
dreams yes yes so there's I think
there's 12 episodes and they're all
individuals I see because I'm looking at
Cranston Steve Buscemi Terence Howard so
they're all stars in different episodes
that's cool that's kind of like Twilight
Zone kind of thing Raymond g Stanley Jr
says dude love the ammo can
yeah that's my buddy Will Perry he makes
these clean ammo cans he made your uh
Tim he's a big fan from Missouri it's a
50 BMG ammo Camp Yeah Tim cast news
politics that was pretty cool
did you bring that in yeah yeah that's
awesome yeah my buddy Will Perry wanted
to give you a gift he's a huge fan we
got a lot of fans in Missouri every time
I go on like all my Missouri just lights
up because they love Tim cast out there
so will gave you this he's got to come
appreciate it where's mine what am I
what am I chopped liver here
a beautiful little George Washington
Buddha that from my shop and I made this
myself so you can get that I'm like all
right Ben D says breaking Biden Biden
student loan Frozen by fed by federal
judge I saw this video apparently it's a
commercial that I don't know if Biden's
putting out where it's like a song about
getting 10K in your pocket and it shows
like jeans and it says 10K flashing and
like people putting money in their
pocket something like that I'm like dude
they're just buying votes yeah basically
that's so insane just like he did with
the marijuana uh decoration which
doesn't affect anyone the Marshalls 500
people are affected
The Marshall Project said not a single
person will be will be released from
prison because of this yeah most people
in prison are for trafficking not for
possession no one's in prison
you're not a single person yeah but then
people are like yeah but you know past
records no no the real and the the big
announcement was going to be the
descheduling because it well
rescheduling he promised that but he
hasn't delivered yeah any of that the
reason that he said they couldn't do
that is because it's a schedule one drug
they can't reschedule it because it's
scheduled it's crazy
there's a lot of money yeah and a lot of
big Industries we just need to change
the culture oh he wants everybody
believes we should be legal to be legal
even when the law is like opiates if you
want to get someone off it sounds like
an anarchist idea there that doesn't
sound very mineral that was a Tim pool
idea that sounds like a change the
culture all right Tim never reads my
Super Chat says oh great show Austin
Peterson is on point as usual also
thanks Tim for reading the original
Second Amendment as first written I'm
tired of liberals purposefully
misinterpreting it all the time that was
cool and thank you appreciate that Tim
never reads my super chats that's right
that's a great name Herman Acosta says
big businesses love laws and regulations
it prices out people from being able to
afford to start a business effect
pulling up the ladder behind them yep
Herman Acosta you're my boy yep
okay what do we got here Kellen Shaw
indie game says idea each vote is
multiplied by how many votes we cast
since the last time that office was
elected if you vote every year your
Senate vote is worth six POTUS worth
four only every four years and counts
less that's interesting I'd like to see
that's kind of along the lines of what
we're talking about there people think
that because they vote every four years
you know that they should have you know
they should have a say but the people
who show up to the town councils the
people who show up to the meetings the
electors who actually engage with
campaigns those people were always
supposed to have more of us you know
what maybe there's an idea every time
you go to a local election you receive a
vote voucher and then on general
election day for like Governor or
whatever those vote vouchers count as
votes or just how about if you just own
property how's that yeah yeah only only
if you're only if you're a white male
who owns property right
but the idea here is if you participate
in all your local elections when you go
to vote at the at the general higher
level you have more say than someone
who's ignored the whole process or how
about if you're just if you're a net
taxpayer
yes which is only the one percent yeah
if you're a net tax leader there you go
I think the net taxpayers are only in
the top 20. what's the net taxpayer so
uh everybody here pays taxes but on
average you receive more tax benefits
than you pay into taxes so I think what
is it everyone receives like 50 Grand so
unless you've paid more than fifty
thousand dollars in taxes you're not a
net taxpayer oh okay yeah and then you
gotta you gotta add that only uh 48 is
it 48 of people actually pay into taxes
yes that's crazy oh yeah the compliance
rates have been much lower actually it
was like what during Eisenhower's years
in the 1950s where the top marginal tax
rate was like 91 and the Liberals are
like we've had much higher tax rates
back in the past but nobody paid it
nobody paid the tax those tax rates
right like there was I mean they just
didn't pay their taxes literally yeah
yeah because the higher it's just the
Laffer Curve right some of the higher
attacks so let's compliance again but
also it's the less actual Revenue you
generate espec especially if people have
the opportunity to leave your
jurisdiction and trade elsewhere that's
people don't understand this man
they don't get it all right everybody uh
let's see maybe we'll try and grab uh
we'll grab one more
ghetto man says just ordered every
documentary on info uh one documentary
one info words do you mean from the
tours on on does it actually in there uh
on Infowars though that means other
people made it got to support the man
who first informed me how corrupt our
government is and here's 20 for talking
about how absurd the whole thing is well
there you go man all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member over at
timcast.com to support our work directly
and watch all of our members only shows
like the timcast uncensored IRL show
check those out plus cast Castle the
last episode was really really fun to
make and you can follow the show at Tim
castirl you can follow me at timcast
Austin do you want to shout anything out
yeah please check out my new morning
talk show the Wake Up America show uh
subscribe to me on YouTube at ap4
Liberty I'm AP for Liberty everywhere
but that's a great place to watch the
show so the Wake Up America show Monday
through Friday 7 A.M to 9 A.M central
time so if you subscribe to my YouTube
AT AP Philly you'll find me and if you
want to get um any of my awesome little
Buddhas that I make myself by hand uh
you can check out the ap4 Liberty shop
AP for libertyshop.com thanks a lot guys
appreciate you having me back it's
awesome yeah awesome this was great
thank you so much for coming to see you
again man it's been years maybe one day
you'll will believe in Freedom
and maybe one day you'll stop talking
about how you love and need government
but meanwhile I enjoyed the conversation
and it was awesome my website is Lucan
sensor.com I got a bunch of stuff there
for um merchandise master classes I did
a video there recently about two things
that I'm doing right now in all of this
craziness Lucan sensor.com hope to see
you there after this video I agree
Austin thank you for being the Spurs in
Luke's butt because I like to watch him
run he's a fast fast fast man horse uh
boy did that joke fall flat bye guys I'm
not gonna be here on Monday I'm taking
the taking the weekend off I'm gonna go
spend some time with family I hopefully
you have the opportunity to do the same
and take advantage of it and I'll see
you Tuesday get in touch with me online
if you want to be in Crossland and I am
surge.com I will be in the chats maybe a
little bit tonight we'll see how that
goes uh it was a good one see ya thanks
man thanks for hanging out everybody we
got a bunch of Clips coming up
throughout the weekend we've got a bunch
of stuff on the website check it out and
we'll see you all next time see ya
cheers